l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour
2024 la parole est à Monsieur Aurélien
Rousseau ministre de la santé et de la
[Applaudissements]
prévention madame madame la
Présidente
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur générale
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
thématiques mesdames et messieurs les
députés il y a quelques jours nous avons
fêté les 78 ans d'un acte fondateur de
notre pacte social moderne je parle bien
sûr des ordonnances de 1945 créant la
sécurité sociale toutes et tous ici nous
sommes encore aujourd'hui réunis autour
de l'héritage
issu de l'Alliance d'apparence
improbable mais c'est peut-être cela qui
fit sa force d'un syndicaliste
communiste devenu député puis ministre
roise croisa et d'un haut fonctionnaire
spécialiste des assurances sociales
pierre laroc dont les parcours
n'auraient sans doute pas dû se croiser
nous sommes les bénéficiaires de ce
système unique de protection social qui
a traversé les décennies et les
gouvernements mais qui a surtout permis
à notre nation peut-être plus que tout
autre peut-être plus que toute autre
politique publique de socialiser les
risques et ainsi de franchir
solidairement les crises car derrière ce
budget qui mobilise chaque année des
sommes supérieures à celles du budget de
l'État il y a évidemment des prestations
des prises en charge des malades soignés
des médecins rémunérés des hôpitaux
rénovés mais je tiens à le redire ici
c'est du budget d'un système d'assurance
sociale que nous discutons un système
d'assurance sociale d'une extraordinaire
perte performance qui est avant tout le
symbole des efforts solidairement
consentis en faveur de notre santé de
nos familles et de nos aînés et de nos
retraite ce régime de protection sociale
c'est l'une de nos plus grandes fiertés
il appartient à chaque citoyen et aux
partenaires sociaux qui en sont les
garant on l'a souvent entendu et répété
mais ce n'est pas en vain car cette
histoire et cette fierté nous oblige
elle nous oblige notamment en cette
séquence annuelle d'examen du projet de
loi de financement de notre sécurité
sociale de poser les éléments sans
détour et donc elle nous oblige à nous
inscrire dans une double approche à la
fois celle de l'action globale car toute
notre politique sociale ne réside pas
dans le seul PLFSS à quelques centaines
de mètres d'ici vos collègues sénateurs
discutent du projet de la proposition de
loi présentée par votre collègue
Frédéric Valtou et dans quelques jours
le dialogue entre les médecins libéraux
et l'assurance maladie va reprendre dans
le cadre
conventionnel double approche disais-je
celle de l'action globale mais celle
aussi du temps long de la pérennité et
de la programmation auquel je sais que
vous êtes nombreux à être attaché sur
les bancs de cette assemblée cette
réflexion j'y suis bien sûr
particulièrement sensible en matière de
santé et de prévention ce projet de loi
le financement de la sécurité sociale ne
s'inscrit pas dans une période normale
si nous si ce n'est plus le covid qui le
soutend si les perspectives d'inflation
sont meilleures pour l'an prochain ce
PLFSS doit répondre aux besoins d'un
système de santé qui reste à la fois
formidable et fragile ainsi et peut-être
surtout ce PLFSS doit d'abord contribuer
à faire confiance à donner et à redonner
confiance confiance dans ce système qui
fut là avant nous et qui continuera de
nous protéger comme de protéger la
génération suivante et celles qui
viendront après confiance dans notre
capacité collective à nous engager et à
prendre nos responsabilité face à ses
fragilités enfin confiance réciproque
les uns dans les autres les pouvoirs
publics les acteurs de la santé la ville
l'hôpital les citoyens et les élus cette
confiance elle se gagne d'abord par la
lucidité sur l'état de notre système de
santé et la transparence mais elle se
gagne aussi en tenant les engagements
pris et en restant toujours lucide et
modeste en relevant que les moyens
déployés n'ont jamais été aussi
importants et commencent je le crois à
porter leurs fruits les 19 milliards
d'euros du segéure investissement
continuent de se déployer ce sont des
murs des toits des équipements ce sont
des établissements reconstruit ou
rénovés pour garantir les de meilleures
conditions d'exercice à nos soignants
une meilleure prise en charge aux
patients ce sont ces engagements qui ont
été au cœur de la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2021 nous avons
complété les revalorisations du Ségure à
hauteur de près d'un milliard et demi
pour accompagner les professionnels des
établissements de santé et
médicau-sociaux et leur garantti c'est
dans le dans le texte qui vous est
soumis à partir d'aujourd'hui et leur
garantir un socle de rémunération
rehaussé en particulier pour celles et
ceux qui nous soignent la nuit le
weekend ou les jours fériers ces moyens
doivent accompagner aussi la reprise de
l'activité notamment hospitalière avec
les campagnes de recrutement les plus
satisfaisantes depuis 10 ans qui
permettent enfin de rouvrir des lits
d'ici la fin de l'année nous devrions
avoir ouvert 1000 à 1500 lits d'hospital
isationtion tout cela vient appuyer une
action qui se déploie non seulement à
travers ce PLFSS mais aussi dans son
articulation avec un ensemble d'autres
vecteurs je pense tout particulièrement
à la reprise des négociations
conventionnelles avec les médecins
libéraux que j'évoqué tout à l'heure et
à la poursuite de la proposition de loi
Visante à de l'examen de la proposition
de loi Visante à améliorer l'accès aux
soins porté par Frédéric Valtou dans
chacune de ces démarches nous sommes
guidés par l'idée de renforcer ce
système afin qu'il protège toujours
mieux les Français et qu'il puisse faire
face aux difficultés auxquelles il est
confronté car oui ces difficultés existe
et je ne céderai jamais à la tentation
de jeter dessus un voile pudique ou de
REP ou de repeindre la façade du haut de
cette tribune la transparence c'est
aussi la marque de cette confiance que
je martè nos débats vont se dérouler
dans un contexte que chacun connaît un
contexte que le gouvernement a tenu à
partager le plus tôt possible avec les
représ ésentant des groupes de cette
assemblée c'est à c'est à cette fin que
nous avons organisé les comptes de
Ségure exercice sans doute forcément
encore perfectible mais qui aura je le
crois eu eu un double mérite d'abord
d'identifier un certain nombre de sujet
sur lequel il nous faudra encore
travailler tous tout ne se retrouveve
pas dans ce texte tous ne relèv
peut-être pas du niveau de la loi mais
je cite très rapidement car ce sont
autant de pistes à creuser des
intervention des députés Maude petit ou
Adrien Clouet qui ne siègent pas sur les
mêmes bancs mais qui ont évoquer la
question de la transparence des prix des
médicaments et notamment ceux à faible
intérêt médical ou encore les députés e
califer et Paul André Colombani pour qui
ont évoqué je reste à leur disposition
pour creuser ce sujet ce célèbre sujet
du coefficient géographique mais dans un
autre registre je pense que jean-fran is
Rousset et Yannick ner qui sont tous les
deux des spécialistes notamment d'un
sujet qui peut paraître secondaire mais
qui est central pour notre système de
santé celui des dispositifs médicaux
méritent un travail de longue haleine
les comptes de Ségure ont eu pour
deuxème mérite de faire œuvre de
transparence sur un certain nombre de
défis je souhaite donc à nouveau
insister sur l'équilibre recherché par
ce projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2024 il doit
permettre à la fois de poursuivre
investissement dans la transformation du
système de santé en donnant la priorité
à l'accès au soins à la valorisation de
l'engagement des soignant et au virage
de la prévention et il doit aussi
permettre de renforcer la pertinence de
de la dépense et la responsabilité de
tous les acteurs face à la croissance
des dépenses de santé grâce à des
mesures de maîtrise de croissance de
cette dépense et de recettees permettant
également d'améliorer l'efficience du
système un mot justement même si Thomas
casaznav y reviendra évidemment sur le
cadrage budgétaire de ce texte il
s'inscrit dans un contexte d'ensemble
contrain par construction marqué par une
inflation qui a été forte cette année et
qui restera même plus faible l'an
prochain une dégradation des comptes de
la sécurité sociale notamment de la
branche maladie certes nous étions à 21
milliards d'euros de déficit en 22 et
nous finirons en dessous de 10 milliards
en 2023 mais ce sont des des chiffres
mais ce sont des chiffres importants et
un fort dynamisme des dépenses de santé
je pense notamment par exemple aux
dépenses de médicaments il vous est
proposé en premier lieu mesdames et
messieurs les députés de rectifier
l'ondame pour 2023 à hauteur de 2,8
milliards d'euros pour intégrer les
revalorisations salariales qui ont été
acquises notamment dans la fonction
publique et la dynamique des soins de
ville je souhaite et je le dit ici
clairement que nous souhaitions que nous
puissions refaire progressivement de
long dam un outil de pilotage et non un
outil de validation de la dépense de
santé puisque quand nous soumettons au
Parlement une rectification de 2,8
milliards d'euros on voit bien que nous
sommes plutôt dans le constat que dans
la maîtrise mieux suivre mieux piloter
mieux maîtriser mieux vous en rendre
compte également c'est un enjeu de
transparence de confiance et de
responsabilité vis-à-vis du Parlement
mais mais vis-à-vis aussi des assurés
sociaux qui cotisent à ces systèmes mais
il est vrai que nous sommes toujours
dans une situation instable ainsi le
gouvernement continuera de se mobiliser
jusqu'à la fin de l'exercice budgétaire
et dès lors qu'il disposera de tous les
chiffres sur l'activité hospitalière
pour prendre en compte les effets de
l'inflation sur les établissements de
santé en
2023 pour l'ONDAM 2024 avec une
évolution prévu à
plus à + 3,2 % hors dépenses lié à la
crise sanitaire cette onable sera bien
sûr supérieur à l'inflation pr
prévisionnelle au total c'est donc une
progression des moyens de 8 milliards
d'euros qui vous est présenté dans ce
PLFSS soit plus que le budget global du
ministère de la Justice il y a encore 2
ans nous n'en sommes pas du tout à la
cure d'austérité pour
2024 traduit par rapport au tendentiel
dynamique des dépenses effectivement des
mesures de maîtrise d'économie ou plus
exactement des mesures de ralentissement
de la dépense et d'efficience pour un
montant de 3,5 milliards d'euros que le
contexte rend indispensable ces mesures
de maîtrise sont de plusieurs natures et
visent à responsabiliser chacun sans
stigmatiser personne les professionnels
de santé comme les assurés bénéficiaires
ou les employeurs sont tous concernés
pour atteindre notre cible
des efforts de modération des volumes et
de baisse des prix doivent permettre de
freiner la hausse des dépenses de
produits de santé des efforts
d'efficience et de pertinence sont
prévus tant pour les soins de ville et
cela sera au cœur de la négociation
conventionnelle que l'ensemble des
syndicats de médecins ont accepté de
reprendre avec ces termes précisément
dans la lettre de cadrage que j'ai
adressé au directeur général de
l'assurance maladie elle sera donc au
cœur de la négociation conventionnelle
mais ce sera aussi le cas pour l'hôpital
avec par exemple une plus grande
efficience dans les achats simultanément
aux efforts très importants que nous
financions en matière d'attractivité et
notamment de réhaussement des
rémunérations enfin des efforts de
responsabilisation des assurés sont
également envisagés avec plusieurs
réflexions ouvertes dont vous avez eu
connaissance et dont nous aurons
l'occasion de débattre mesdames et
messieurs les députés j'estime qu'il y a
un enjeu démocratique dans le fait de
présenter au Parlement un texte qui nous
permette d'assurer la pérennité de notre
modèle social je sais que sur tous les
bancs vous êtes attaché à cette
préoccupation que vous êtes également
attaché à la lutte contre la fraude ou
plutôt les fraudes qui contribuent tout
à la fois à cette à cette
insoutenabilité du système et qui sont
le corolaire de notre quête de justice
sociale en la matière tout ne se résume
pas au PLFSS mais il est néanmoins
indispensable aujourd'hui d'insister sur
le sur ce point car fraudé s'est miné
cette confiance dans le système de
protection sociale
qui ne peut tenir que si chacun prend sa
juste part ce cadrage posé il m'importe
aussi de revenir sur deux des grandes
priorités de politique de santé publique
que ce PLFSS traduit le premier c'est
d'accélérer et de rendre irréversible le
virage de la prévention notre pays a
besoin d'une véritable politique de
prévention pour rompre avec un système
historiquement tourné vers le tout
curatif la prévention doit être et sera
notre grande ambition pour les
prochaines années elle elle s'incarne
déjà dans les grandes opérations de
dépistage et de santé publique en cours
je pense notamment à la campagne de
vaccination contre les infections liées
au papillom virirus prise en charge à
100 % dans tous les collèges pour les
élèves de
5e la gratuité des préservatifs
masculins et féminins pour les moins de
26 ans je ne me suis pas trompé la prise
en charge des protections menstruelles
réutilisables pour les moins de 26 ans
et les plus précaires ce texte pose déjà
long et vous êtes nombreux à proposer
des des enrichissements que je salue
sans être exhaustif je pense en
particulier au dépistage précace précoce
des situations de handicap P pourrant
être induites par des infections
acittomégalovirus pendant le premier
trimestre de grossesse et je remercie la
rapporteur général Stéphan riste de
proposer cette avancée je pense
également à la volonté de crier de créer
des filières psychiatriques dans les
services d'accès aux soins que le
gouvernement soutient pleinement des
avancées seront également rendu possible
notamment par le biais de la
généralisation d'expérimentation de
l'article 51 en matière d'activité
physique adaptée et nous poursuivrons
les débats sur ce sujet et je mentionne
ici également le cannabis thérapeutique
qui fera l'objet d'un nouveau cadre dans
l'attente de l'issue des travaux
européens afin de préserver l'accès des
patients dans les cinq indications
thérapeutiques de l'ex expérimentation
et je remercie notamment les députés
Caroline janvier et ludéovic mendz pour
leur investissement de longue date à ce
sujet le deuxième grand objectif de ce
texte c'est de moderniser le
fonctionnement du système de santé pour
améliorer l'accès aux soins et toujours
mieux répondre aux besoins de santé de
nos concitoyens dans la ligée des
avancées en faveur d'un meilleur partage
des compétences et d'un accès plus
direct aux professionnels de santé ce
texte permet un élargissement des
compétences des pharmaciens par exemple
en matière de prescription
d'antibiotiques après la réalisation
d'un Tex d'un test rapide d'orientation
diagnostique pour les engines et les
cystites simples c'est une mesure qui va
dans le même sens que tout le travail
déjà réalisé autour de l'élargissement
des compétences vaccinales autour du
partage des tâches avec des
professionnels de santé de proximité qui
sont mobilisés fortement autour de cette
dynamique moderniser notre système de
santé pour améliorer l' ACC aux soins
c'est aussi s'appuyer sur les
expérimentations et initiatives locales
ainsi le PLFSS prévoit la création d'un
forfait permettant de financer des
équipes de soins dans une logique de
généralisation de certaines
expérimentations pour ne plus être
simplement tenu à la rémunération à
l'activité cette mesure permet l'entrée
dans le droit commun de dispositifs qui
ont fait leur preuve reposant sur une
logique de parcours de coopération de
financement innovant et solidaire
adaptable aux besoins des patients qui
permet notamment la prise en charge de
nouvelles prestations dans le cadre de
forfait moderniser et transformé suppose
aussi de faire évoluer le financement
des établissements de santé presque 20
ans après la réforme mettant en place la
T2A ces effets positifs comme ses
limites sont largement documentés le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale répond à l'ambition
fixée par le Président de la République
de mettre fin au caractère central de la
T2A faisant place à une part
structurante de la rémunération sur des
objectifs de santé publique négocié à
l'échelle d'un territoire et permettant
une rémunération effective des missions
réalisées par chacun toutes ces mesures
visent à améliorer l'accès aux soins de
qualité à nos concitoyens y compris les
plus précaires le texte prévoit ainsi
une meilleure articulation de la
complémentaire santé solidaire avec
certains minimas sociaux dont
laallocation adulte handicapé permettant
à nos concitoyens les plus fragiles
d'accéder plus facilement à une
complémentaire c'est une mesure concrète
de progrès social transformer et
protéger le système de santé c'est
finalement lutter toujours mieux contre
certains
excès je sais notamment que la
rapporteur générale est particulièrement
attentive à cette question et je suis
convaincu notamment que nous devrons au
cours des mois qui viennent avancer sur
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans
certains champs de la santé que l'on
peut qualifier de financiarisation un
mécanisme qui a vu totalement se
transformer le secteur de la biologie
médicale qui qui se joue actuellement
par exemple dans la radiologie mais nous
devons si nous souhaitons pouvoir
continuer à piloter les politiques de
santé publique mieux comprendre mieux
connaître ce qui se passe j'ai eu
l'occasion de l'évoquer devant la
commission mais dès à présent je salue
les propositions d'un certain nombre
d'entre vous autour de Stéphanie riste
pour clarifier au bénéfice des patients
et de la qualité des parcours les
modalités de financement de certains
secteurs notamment la radiothérapie et
la dialyse enfin ce texte porte
plusieurs mesures importantes relatives
à l'accès aux médicaments c'est bien sûr
un sujet de préoccupation pour nos
concitoyens notamment à l'approche de
l'hiver un sujet sur lequel nous sommes
mobilisés au quotidien notamment pour le
suivi des stocks sur les médicaments les
plus importants le texte qui vous est
soumis prévoit de compléter les outils
de gestion des tensions
d'approvisionnement et des situations de
pénurie que nous connaissons
périodiquement et que nous avons connu
très fortement l'an dernier c'est le cas
notamment avec la disp pensation à
l'unité ou encore la limitation des
prescriptions par téléconsultation lors
des tensions ou pénuries au-delà de la
gestion de ces situations sont prévu des
mesures d'amélioration de l'accès aux
médicaments et actes de diagnostic
innovant sans que cela ne se fasse au
détriment de l'accès au produits plus
matur essentiel pour soigner les
Français au quotidien et qui doivent
être protégés mesdames et messieurs les
députés vous le voyez ce texte s'efforce
de répondre à des besoins urgents avec
des mesures d'application directes je
pense notamment à la valorisation du
travail de nuit tout en préparant et en
consolidant l'avenir du système de santé
son cadrage général répond à la double
exigence d'ambition et de soutenabilité
qui doit irriguer l'ensemble de notre
action publique il sera je le crois
profondément un socle solide sur lequel
nous pourrons continuer de construire
avec réalisme et détermination il est
loin bien évidemment d'être un solde de
tout compte au contraire sur beaucoup de
sujets je le prends comme une ouverture
pour nos travaux des mois à venir je
pense par exemple je l'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure au défi que représente la
financiarisation d'une partie de notre
système de santé j'ai parlé aussi de
prévention je l'ai dit devant la
délégation au droits des femmes je crois
que nous devons et que nous pouvons
progresser sur la santé des femmes je
l'ai réaffirmé la semaine dernière je
pense que nous pouvons et devons
travailler dans les prochaines semaines
et les prochains mois sur cet enjeu
majeur de la santé mentale et
j'accueille avec beaucoup d'intérêt les
les propos i de différents groupes de
cette assemblée je pense encore à la
lutte contre les addictions et le tabac
je sais que c'est un sujet qui tient à
cœur de nombre d'entre vous avec qui je
discuterai dans les prochains dans les
prochaines semaines pour la présentation
du plan national de lutte contre le
tabac sur tous ces sujets comme sur de
nombreux autres je m'attacherai
évidemment à faire vivre la discussion
tout au long de l'année avec l'ensemble
des commissions concernés et des
parlementaires
engagés sur tous les bords de cette
assemblée en effet
comme Pierre laroc et embroise croisa
nous l'ont montré à leur époque il n'est
pas nécessaire d'être parfaitement
d'accord sur tout pour faire confiance
débattre construire et avancer et ainsi
faire œuvre utile au service des
Françaises et des Français et de
l'intérêt général au fond le seul qui
compte je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur Thomas
casazna ministre délégué chargé des
comptes
publics
monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente Madame la
la présidente de la commission des
Affaires social madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre madame la la
rapporteur générale Mesdames et
Messieurs les les rapporteurs
thématiques je suis heureux de vous
présenter ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale avec
mes collègues Aurore Berg et Aurélien
Rousseau ce texte nous pouvons en être
fiers nous pouvons en être fier car il
continue d'investir massivement dans la
protection sociale et dans la santé des
Français nous pouvons en être fier car
il développe de nouveaux axes en matière
de prévention en santé et d'accès de nos
concitoyens aux thérapies dont ils ont
besoin nous pouvons en être fi aussi car
il traduit nos engagement dans le champ
de l'autonomie par exemple en donnant
les moyens de recruter dans les épades
ou de mieux identifier accompagner les
enfants en situation handicap nous
pouvons en être fi car il porte ses
priorités tout en assurant la maîtrise
et dépenses condition indispensable pour
préserver notre système à court et à
long terme nous pouvons en être fier
enfin car ce texte apporte des mesures
nouvelles et très fermes dans la lutte
contre la fraude qui est un enjeu
financier mais aussi et surtout un enjeu
de cohésion sociale aussi ce PLFSS
répond je le crois à l'aspiration des
Français en faveur d'un système de
protection sociale équitable et pérenisé
avant de vous présenter plus en détail
l'équilibre financier les mesures que
porte ce PLFSS je souhaite rappeler le
cap qui a été le mien et que je sais
être une préoccupation pour la plupart
d'entre vous il s'agit tout simplement
de la soutenabilité de notre système
nous ne pouvons pas fermer les yeux sur
la question financière il en va de notre
capacité à pouvoir affronter sere
les crises de demain nous avons su
pendant les années de crise covid mettre
en place le quoi qu'il en coûte nous
avons su accompagner les établissements
face à l'envolé des prix de l'énergie le
niveau de dépenses et de déficit que
nous avons connu pendant la crise n'est
cependant pas soutenable dans la durée
il ne peut pas devenir notre point de
référence les recettes ne peuvent pas
devenir la variable d'ajustement pour
résorber nos déficits cette logique est
valable pour la sécurité sociale comme
pour les finances publiques dans leur
ensemble nous avons pour objectif
mesdames et messieurs les députés de
réduire le déficit public sous la barre
des 3 % à horizon 2027 ce n'est pas un
totem ce sont les marges de manœuvre de
demain ce n'est pas non plus hors de
portée c'est tout simplement le niveau
de déficit que nous avions avant crise
en 2018 et 2019 nous pouvons y revenir
et nous y reviendrons à condition que
l'effort soit partagé état collectivité
locale et sécurité sociale enfin comme
vous le savez dans le champ social
maîtriser les dépenses c'est nager
contre le courant la dynamique naturelle
des dépenses joue en sens contraire
c'est l'effet de la démographie du
vieillissement mais aussi du
renchérissement associé au progrès
médical les mesures de maîtrise sont
donc absolument nécessaires pour ne pas
voir le système dérivé ce PLFSS
s'inscrit donc pleinement dans notre
trajectoire de maîtrise des dépenses
publiques et dans l'objectif de
soutenabilité de long terme mais ce
PLFSS n'est pour autant pas synonyme
d'austérité loin de là c'est un texte
qui traduit encore une fois une priorité
très claire donnée à nos politiques
sociales et à notre politique de santé
ce texte assure des moyens
historiquement élevés aux établissements
de santé ces derniers ces derniers ont
bénéficié d'un important soutien
financier de l'Assurance Maladie ces
dernières années par exemple 6,5
milliards d'euros ont été versés depuis
2020 au titre du désendettement
hospitalier le Ségure a représenté au
total 13,4 milliards d'euros en 2023
pour investir et pour des mesures
salariales je rappelle aussi qu'un
amortisseur électricité a été mis en
place pour faire face à la crise des
prix de l'énergie et a permis de limiter
la hausse des coûts pour un montant
estimé à près de 300 millions d'euros le
soutien public au financement des
hôpitaux restera massif en
2024 le sous-objectif qui leur est dédié
dépassera en effet 100 milliards d'euros
pour la 2e année consécutive soit un
niveau historique s'agissant plus
spécifiquement de la compensation de
l'inflation en 2023 qui fait l'objet de
plusieurs amendements de votre part je
rappelle qu'elle est prise en compte
dans l'endame 2023 pour une enveloppe de
800 millions d'euros pour les hôpitaux
et plus de 200 millions d'euros destinés
aux établissements médicaux-sociaux dans
le champ médicau-social longondame 2023
intègre les 100 millions d'euros
annoncés par la première ministre cet
été dans le cadre d'un nouveau fond
d'urgence ce dispositif permettra
d'accompagner les éepades et les
services à domicile rencontrant des
difficultés financières ce PLFSS prévoit
aussi dans la continuité notamment du
rapport de Madame Christine pirzbonne
une évolution du financement des éepad
pour les département volontaire plus
largement l'ONDA médico-social couvrant
le champ du grand âge et du handicap
dépassera pour la première fois les 30
milliards d'euros enfin de manière
transversale aux établissements
sanitaires et médicau-sociaux le PLFSS
prolonge les acquis des dernières années
en matière de revalorisation salariale
en 2024 les mesures de revalorisation et
d'attractivité décidé en 2023 coûteront
3,3 milliards d'euros si on inclut le
relèvement du point d'indice de 3,5 % de
2022 ce sont 6,2 milliards d'euros de
gains pour les professionnels l'année
prochaine qui viennent s'ajouter aux
mesures ségures prises au moment de la
crise sanitaire au total l'ondame 2024
progressera donc de 3,2 % soit un niveau
supérieur à celui de l'inflation qui
s'établira quant à elle à 2,5 %. sur le
quinquena l'ONDAM sera systématiquement
supérieur à l'inflation en dehors de
l'ondame je souhaite rappeler que le
gouvernement maintient un système
protecteur d'indexation des prestation
sur l'inflation qui pour les retraites
représente 14 milliards d'euros et pour
les prestations familiales plus d'un
milliard d'euros ces montants reflètent
un engagement une priorité un
investissement pour protéger tous les
Français dans ce contexte nous
construisons une trajectoire graduelle
de rétablissement des comptes le
dynamisme de l'emploi est le premier
déterminant de cette trajectoire parce
qu'il permet une évolution dynamique des
cotisations sociales qui sont le socle
du financement de notre sécurité sociale
je rappelle que 2 millions d'emplois ont
été créés depuis 2017 et que nous
continuerons sur cette voie nous tirons
aussi le bénéfice des réformes conduites
ces dernières années je pense notamment
au réformes de l'assurance chômage et
des retraites porté par mon collègue
Olivier duopt il nous faut préserver ce
bénéfice absolument cela concerne
notamment l'agir Carco l'objectif de
sanctuariser les économies réalisées a
été présenté de manière transparente
depuis le début de la concertation sur
la réforme des retraites y compris dans
une logique de solidarité
interrégime comme vous le savez les
partenaires sociaux se sont accordés
début octobre sur un accord créateur de
dépenses nouvelles des retraites
complémentaires mais notre volonté
demeure de continuer à avancer par la
voie du dialogue
social c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi à
ce stade nous ne déposerons pas
d'amendement réduisant les recettes du
régime agir
Carco l'article 9 de Laan ouvre la porte
à une nouvelle discussion sur le
financement de dispositifs de solidarité
nous souhaitons donc que les partenaires
sociaux s'engage s'engage sur cette base
pour définir un cofinancement des
minimas de pension des salariés ou
d'autres dispositifs de solidarité à
partir de 2024 ou bien même comme nous
l'avions évoquer un échange de taux
entre les cotisations du régime général
et les cotisations du régime
complémentaire à du concurrence nous
demandons nous demandons des avancées
concrètes et rapides sur ce point dans
le temps ouvert par la navette
parlementaire car nous demeurons
déterminés à garantir l'équilibre du
système des retraites d'ici
2030 par ailleurs par ailleurs toujours
pour sécuriser la réduction de notre
déficit public dè 2024 nous serons
favorables à un amendement porté par
plusieurs membres de la majorité pour
réduire l'augmentation des allègement de
charg à la suite des travaux de la
mission d'évaluation et de contrôle des
lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale de Monsieur Marc feratci et de
Monsieur Jérôme Gedge nous stabiliserons
les barêes à leur niveau de 2023
agissant des bornes à 2,5 SMIC et 3,5
SMIC ce qui évitera une perte de
recettees de l'ordre de 600 millions
d'euros pour la sécurité sociale si nous
agissons donc sur les ressources de la
sécurité sociale de nouvelles mesures de
maîtrise et dépenses sont nécessaires
dès 2024 et d'autres devont être prises
à partir de 2025 en 2024 longam intègre
ainsi 3,5 milliards d'euros d'économie
ces économies seront un effort parti
entre tous les acteurs du système de
santé c'est-à-dire aussi bien les
assurés que les prescripteurs ou les
industriels je veux par ailleurs
souligner que les mesures d'économie que
nous proposons répondent non seulement à
des enjeux financiers mais aussi à des
impératifs sanitaires et
environnementaux ce
PLFSS confirme ainsi qu'il existe une
voie pour une forme de sobriété et que
les objectifs financiers sanitaires et
environnementaux peuvent être
réconciliés ces 3,5 milliards d'euros
d'économie seront donc un effort partagé
1,3 milliard d'euros d'économie sont
attendu de la responsabilisation des
assurés cette dernière peut passer par
un ensemble de leviers qui ne relève pas
nécessairement de mesures législatives
en PLFSS et qui sont en train d'être
travaillé et concerté par le ministre en
charge de la santé et de la prévention
les économies pourraient ainsi résulter
de la hausse des franchise et
participation forfaitaire qui n'ont pas
augmenté depuis leur création il y a
près de 20 ans ou de la hausse du ticket
modérateur correspondant à la part de
prise en charge par l'assurée ou par sa
mutuelle une telle évolution est par
exemple intégré au PLFSS s'agissant des
soins dentaires la responsabilisation
des assurés doit aussi permettre des
dépenses plus efficientes par exemple en
recourant au transport sanitaires
partagés qui est également plus
favorable à l'environnement ou en
privilégiant chaque fois que possible
les médicaments génériques ou
biosimilaires la consommation des
médicaments doit être maîtrisé il en va
de la responsabilité des assurés comme
des
prescripteurs 1,3 milliard d'euros
d'économies sont attendu également sur
les dépenses de méd médicaments et
dispositifs médicaux dont 1 milliard au
titre de la baisse des prix et 300
millions d'euros du fait de la baisse et
volume pour y parvenir deux mesures sont
pr prévu dans le PLFSS la première
conditionne la délivrance
d'antibiotiques pour certaines
pathologies à la réalisation d'un test
en confirmant l'utilité la deuxième
prévoit d'activer des mesures d'épargne
telles que le conditionnement à l'unité
et les ordonnances conditionnel en cas
de risque de rupture de stock de
médicaments je souhaite d'ailleurs que
des travaux soient engagés pour
généraliser ces mesures en dehors des
période de rupture d'approvisionnement
900 millions d'euros d'économie enfin
viendront des soins de ville et des
mesures d'efficience à
l'hôpital concernant les soins de ville
les économies sont liées à la réforme du
financement des produits de contraste
utilisés dans l'imagerie médicale qui
entrera en vigueur en 2024 et à la
baisse des tarifs de biologie dans les
hôpitaux et les établissements
médicaux-sociaux les mesures
d'efficience notamment sur les achats
ainsi que les actions engagées en
matière de pertinence et d'efficience
des soins devront permettre d'atteindre
600 millions d'euros d'économie en
2024 ces économies ces économies
viennent en plus des mesures nécessaires
de maîtrise médicalisée de l'ensemble
des dépenses de santé qui recouvrent
l'ensemble des actions engagées par
l'assurance maladie qui devront être
renforcé en 2024 par exemple pour
accompagner les prescriptions d'actes
médicaux ou de médicaments pour
2025 pour 2025 nous devrons faire 6
milliards d'euros d'économie
supplémentaire comme le prévoit la loi
de programme
des finances publiques enfin j'ai
souhaité que ce PLF SS comme d'ailleurs
le PLF soit celui de la lutte contre la
fraude c'est un impératif d'équité et de
justice sociale pour l'ensemble des
assurés il n'est pas admissible que
certains éludent leurs cotisation
perçoivent indumement des prestations
abusent de leur expertise ou comme nous
l'avons vu dans l'actualité récente
facilite la fraude la fraude est une
violation du contrat social qui est au
fondement de notre sécurit sociale c'est
pourquoi ce PLFSS prévoit plusieurs
mesures le circuit de paiement des
cotisations des travailleurs de
plateforme sera sécurisé garantissant
leur paiement mais aussi l'acquisition
de droits nouveaux pour ces travailleurs
cette mesure sera mise en œuvre à partir
de 2026 auprès de certaines plateformes
et généralisé en 2027 les sanctions
contre les professionnels de santé
fraudeurs seront renforcés ainsi les
professionnels concernés devront
rembourser les cotisations prises en
charge par l'Assurance Maladie les
travaux d'évaluation de la CNAM rendus
public la semaine dernière ont renforcé
notre détermination sur le sujet sur 316
millions d'euros de fraudte détecté en
2022 68 % sont le fait de professionnel
de santé le dispositif de l'avance
immédiate au crédit d'impôt service à la
personne qui simplifie l'accès à ces
services mais qui est de manière
démontrée à l'origine de nouveaux
schémas de fraude sera
sécurisé je voudrais aussi revenir sur
la mesure concernant le contrôle des
arrêts de travail je sais qu'elle
suscite des inquiétudes mais nous avons
trouver un bon équilibre la mesure
simplifie le circuit de contrôle des
arrêts maladies et rend ce contrôle plus
effectif tout en préservant les droits
des assurés c'est un premier pas vers
une plus grande maîtrise et dépenses
d'indemnité journalière qui sont très
dynamiques nous poursuivrons cette année
des travaux et des concertations en vue
d'une réforme plus structurelle en 2025
5 nous avons enfin souhaité avec Aurore
berger créer un délit de promotion et de
facilitation de la frude sociale il est
tout simplement insupportable que
certains ne se contentent pas de frauder
mais se
ventent encore d'inciter les autres à le
faire et pire encore d'en faire le
commerce c'est pourquoi j'ai souhaité
que soit déposé un amendement au PLFSS
en ce sens pendant du délit qui sera
instauré pour l'incitation à la fraudte
fiscale dans le PLF le PLFSS s'inscrit
ainsi dans la mise en œuvre du plan de
lutte contre toutes les fraudes par
ailleurs doté de moyens humains
renforcés je profite donc de cette
occasion pour remercier les agents des
organismes de protection sociale et de
Bery pleinement mobilisés dans ce cadre
je suis heureux de pouvoir indiquer que
pour ces derniers nous allons PLF
remédier à une incohérence des textes
encadrant la prise en compte des revenus
sur lesquels ils ont cotisé pour
l'établissement de leurs pension
l'indemnité de technicité sera prise en
compte dans la retraite des
fonctionnaires de Bery ayant pris leur
retraite alors qu'ils étaient en
mobilité avant de conclure mon
intervention je souhaiterais évoquer
notre discussion à venir nous devons
adopter une loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale en conformité avec les
textes organiques dont nous sommes
collectivement doté la dernière loi
organique sur ce sujet date du début
d'année 2022
elle a été votée une large majorité par
vous tous nous étions alors d'accord sur
la nécessité de ces textes qui donnent
un cadre financier àprès de la moitié de
la dépense publique du fait de la loi
organique relative aux loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale aucun
autre texte ne peut par ailleurs
autoriser les organismes de sécurité
sociale à recourir à l'emprunt ce qu'ils
devront faire en 2024 comme les années
précédentes enfin il n'existe pas de
procédure de carence pas de budget par
12e dans le cas de la sécurité sociale
donc même si les crédits ne sont pas
limitatifs il en résulterait une grande
désorganisation du finan cement et une
absence totale de pilotage je constate
d'ailleurs que le texte a été rejeté en
commission des affaires sociales mais
une majorité de rejet n'est pas une
majorité pour un projet
alternatif nous sommes extrêmement
attentifs au débat de commission et à
ceux qui vont s'ouvrir en séance
publique car je sais que sur certains
sujets nous pouvons trouver et nous
avons trouvé des points de convergence
je veux en donner plusieurs exemples
au-delà de l'évolution des allègements
généraux que j'ai évoqué il y a quelques
instants
nous avons fait le choix de retenir
votre proposition sur la généralisation
du dépistage du sitoégalovirus pendant
la grossesse en déposant un amendement
du Gouvernement qui permettra de
l'intégrer au PLFSS nous pouvons aussi
nous rejoindre sur des mesures
d'ajustement des financements par
exemple sur la dialyse et la
radiothérapie que vous avez adopté en
commission à l'initiative de la
rapporteur générale en conclusion je
voudrais vous redire ma détermination
celle de trouver les ressources
nécessaires pour la mise en œuvre des
prix priorité fondamentalement partagé
en matière sanitaire et sociale mais
aussi celle de mettre en œuvre des
mesures de maîtrise de la dépense qui
sont nécessaires pour la soutenabilité
de notre système comme en matière de
santé publique et d'environnement je
vous remercie pour votre attention merci
monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Aurore berger ministre des
Solidarités et des
famille
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres madame la Présidente de la
Commission des Affaires social madame la
rapporteur générale Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les députés je suis heureuse
de pouvoir vous présenter avec Aurélien
Rousseau et Thomas kaznav ce projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2024 les sujets que je
porte au ministère des solidarités et
des familles sont au cœur des besoins
essentiels de nos concitoyens et donc de
nécessaire renforcement de nos services
publics il s'agit de nos familles de nos
enfants de la réponse à leurs besoins à
leur épanouissement et à leur
développement il est de notre
responsabilité absolue de lutter contre
la baisse structurelle de la natalité et
donc de renforcer l'accompagnement à
toutes les familles en cohérence avec
une conception universelle de la
politique familiale la politique
familiale ne saurait devenir une
politique de redistribution ou de
correction des inégalités elle est
d'abord une politique qui appuie et qui
soutient toutes les famille dans le
respect de leurs choix il s'agit aussi
de nos aînés de nos parents et du
soutien à leur autonomie nous faisons
ainsi grandir la branche autonomie pour
relever le défi démographique qui est
devant nous soutenir toutes les familles
c'est évidemment soutenir tous les âges
de la vie il s'agit encore des personnes
en situation de handicap pour leur
assurer tout simplement une vie comme
les autres parmi les autres pour que le
droit commun s'applique à tous Nous
créons d'ici 2030 50000 solutions pour
garantir l'inclusion et la participation
des personnes en situation de handicap à
toutes les étapes de leur vie les
familles d'abord elles sont dans toute
leur diversité le premier maillon de
notre société le creuser des
apprentissages fondamentaux de la vie
collective et de l'expression des
solidarités le retour du terme famille
dans la dénomination du ministère n'est
d'ailleurs pas un hasard c'est la
réaffirmation d'une priorité de nos
politiques publiques je souhaite
m'inscrire dans la ligée de ce choix
fort que notre pays a fait après la
guerre aider toutes les familles et s'en
donner les moyens la branche famille
cher Paul Christophe consacre comme vous
le savez plus de 50 milliards d'euros
chaque année à cet objectif avec une
hausse du budget de 2 milliards d'euros
en 2024 et une trajectoire qui atteindra
63 milliards d'euros de dépenses en 2027
notamment avec la mise en place du du
complément de mode de garde pour toutes
les familles
monoparentales pour mettre en œuvre
concrètement cette politique familiale
le PLFSS intégre à la fois des aides
monétaires comme l'aide de soutien aux
familles c'est-à-dire la pension
alimentaire minimale que nous avons
revalorisé augmenté de 50 % l'année
dernière mais aussi de nouveaux moyens
pour renforcer les services aux familles
simplifier leur vie et mieux répondre à
leurs besoins en respectant leur choix
en 2024 les moyens consacrés à la
politique familiale augmenteront not
notamment pour mettre en œuvre le
chantier du service public de la petite
enfance qui vise à garantir à T parents
l'accès à une solution d'accueil et de
qualité en toute sécurité pour leurs
enfant en crèche chez une assistante
maternelle proche de ces de chez eux et
financièrement accessible et je remercie
le compromis qui a été trouvé en
commission mixte paritaire par les
parlementaires et notamment la
rapporteur Christine lenabour en tout ce
sont 6 milliards d'euros qui seront
consacrés à ce service public jusqu'en
2027 pour revaloriser les professionnel
de la petite enfance soutenir
l'investissement et le fonctionnement
des crèches et engager la dynamique
d'ouverture des 200000 solutions
d'accueil manquante aujourd'hui que ce
soit en accueil collectif ou en accueil
individuel au total la trajectoire de la
branche famille atteindra donc comme je
l'ai dis 63 milliards d'euros de
dépenses en 2027 en ajoutant le
financement du complément mode de garde
pour toutes les familles monoparentales
jusqu'au 11 ans révolu de l'enfant à
partir de l'année
prochaine je m'assurerai que ces moyens
soi dépenser efficacement c'est-à-dire
au service de la qualité de la prise en
charge de nos enfants et de la sécurité
de nos enfants pas un seul des 200
millions d'euros dédiés chaque année à
partir du 1er janvier 2024 à leur
revalorisation des professionnels nira
aux structures qui ne tiendrai pas leurs
engagements pris pour améliorer les
conditions de travail des professionnels
de la petite enfance ce qui veut dire
revalorisation des grilles des bas
salaires formation reprise de
l'ancienneté en clair enfin assume que
ces métiers sont des métiers essentiels
je n'ignore pas l'écart grandissant
entre le désir d'enfant et le nombre
d'enfants mis au monde chaque année dans
chaque famille avec une natalité en
baisse tendantielle depuis 10 ans le
service public de la petite- enfance
c'est un premier élément de réponse mais
nous devons aller bien au-delà en levant
les tabous notamment le sujet de
l'infertilité travaux que nous lançons
avec le ministre de la santé et de la
prévention en laissant aussi plus de
liberté de choix aux familles avec la
réforme du congé parental sur laquelle
je me suis engagée et je mènerait dès
demain une concertation avec l'ensemble
des organisations syndicales et
patronales en écho aux engagements de la
première ministre de la semaine dernière
notre engagement est qu'il évolue verire
une période d'interruption choisie mieux
rémunérée et partagée entre les parents
devenir parent ne doit jamais être un
frein ni un frein à la vie
professionnelle ni un frein à la vie
sociale et c'est évidemment en cela que
nous devons travailler nous avons la
responsabilité collective de permettre à
toutes les familles de choisir librement
et réellement leur organisation
familiale et la manière avec laquelle
ell concilient leur vie quelle que soit
la configuration familiale les
solidarités et la famille c'est
évidemment tout au long de la vie c'est
pour ça que plus que jamais l'autonomie
est au cœur de l'action de mon ministère
au cœur des solidarités d'une part parce
que derrière la question de l'autonomie
se cache la prise en compte de toutes
les fragilités et l'exigence de garantir
effectivement les droits de chacun et
d'assurer la pleine participation à la
vie collective au cœur des familles
évidemment d'autre part parce que toutes
les familles sont concernées par la
perte d'autonomie d'un enfant d'un
conjoint d'une mère d'un grand-père et
qu'il est de notre devoir d'accompagner
ses familles et plus particulièrement de
prendre soin de ceux qui prennent soin
des autres au corps de mon action donc
parce que je suis convaincue que c'est
collectivement que nous ferons face au
défis démographiques en adaptant dès
maintenant notre société au
vieillissement deux chiffres en 2030 un
français sur tr aura plus de 60 ans et
pour la première fois de l'histoire de
notre pays les plus de 65 ans seront
plus nombreux que les moins de 15 ans en
cohérence donc avec cette nécessité
d'adaptation l'objectif global de
dépenses qui finance vous le savez nos
établissements pour personnes âgées et
personnes en situation de handicap
augmentera de 4 % en 2024 soit bien plus
que les 2,6 % d'inflation anticipée
cette hausse importante des moyens
traduit le respect de nos engagementsvs
les familles et les profit professionnel
du secteur ces engagements vous les
connaissez je l'ai dit je crois
profondément au libre choix des
individus et le premier choix des
Français c'est d'abord de pouvoir
vieillir chez eux c'est pour répondre à
cette volonté que nous avons entrepris
le virage domiciliaire et que nous
mettrons en œuvre dès 2024 ma
primeadapte une nouvelle aide financière
pour adapter le logement et surtout pour
prévenir aussi la perte d'autonomie avec
les moyens du PLFSS 2024 nous allons
également poursuivre le développement de
nouveaux centres de ressources
territoriaux pour enfin décloisonner les
interventions auprès des personnes âgées
à domicile et simplifier leur démarche
ces centres de ressources s'incrivent
évidemment dans la dynamique du service
public départemental de l'autonomie qui
devra permettre d'avoir enfin un guichet
unique humain physique pour mettre fin
au parcours du combattant voir parfois
d'herance des personnes directement
concernées mais aussi de leur famille ce
projet d'humanisation et de
simplification de nos services publics
très ancré au cœur des territoires a
commencé à se concrétiser j'ai adressé
l'appel à manifestation d'intérêt dès
cette rentrée au Conseil départementaux
pour sélectionner les premiers
départements pilotes dans le
prolongement des réformes structurelles
que nous menons pour développer
accompagner les services à domicile des
moyens supplémentaires sont dédiés à
cette montée en charge je pense
notamment à l'instauration évidemment du
tarif plancher de l'aide à domicile à 22
€ en 2022 à 23 € en 2023 qui sera indexé
indirectement sur l'inflation dès
l'année prochaine la création d'une
dotation complémentaire de 3 € 10 bonus
qualité pour garantir l'amélioration de
la qualité du service rendu à l'usager
la création de 25000 nouvelles places
CAD d'ici 2030 afin qu'ils offrent un
accompagnement adapté à toutes les
personnes en perte d'autonomie surtout
les plus vulnérables enfin les 2 heures
supplémentaires par semaine dédié à
l'accompagnement à la lutte contre
l'isolement social pour les bénéficiaire
de la pas qui s'appliquera dès le 1er
janvier 2024 nous irons plus loin la
semaine du 20 novembre dans le cadre de
l'examen de la proposition de loi bien
vieillir et je tiens à saluer
l'engagement des deux rapporteurs Annie
Vidal et Laurence Cristol ce texte
permettra des avancées très concrètes
pour les aides à domicile grâce
notamment à la carte professionnelle à
la création d'un fond de soutien à la
mobilité pour qu'enfin elle n'ait plus à
payer pour avoir le droit de travailler
l'apport déterminant de ces femmes car à
99 % ce sont des femmes c'est le métier
le plus féminisé de notre pays à notre
société mais évidemment plus approuvé et
pourtant ces travailleuses de première
ligne sont parmi les plus mésestimés du
secteur médico-social nous devons donc
continuer à mieux reconnaître et mieux
valoriser ses métiers car c'est tout
simplement une question de dignité et
une question de justice je veux
remercier la mobilisation de longue de
long date pardon de Dafna mouchenenck et
de Myriam el comery qui ont mené un
travail remarquable dans le cadre du
Conseil national de la refondation
bienveillir ainsi que les travaux
évidemment parlementaires Caroline
janvier ou d'astr panauan Bouvet
notamment très mobilisé sur ces enjeux
parce que je souhaite que nous
proposions enfin un véritable parcours
résidentiel Michel Cosson est l'un des
promoteurs de ces sujets adaptés donc
aux besoins et aux envies de nos
concitoyens nous devons développer sur
l'ensemble de notre territoire des
structur d'habitat intermédiairees qui
aujourd'hui manque cruellement il y a le
virage domiciliaire il y a nos épades
mais il y a évidemment tout ce parcours
que nous devons créer et en faveur du
développement de l'habitat inclusif nous
allourons dès 2023 et 2024 plusieurs
millions d'euros au conseils
départementaux pour permettre cette
montée en charge nous devrons aller bien
au-delà pour garantir ces logiques de
parcours d'abord pour consolider et
assurer la qualité de l'offre
d'accompagnement des personnes âgées en
établissement vous le savez le pfss 2024
concrétise une nouvelle étape dans notre
engagement de 50000 postes
supplémentaires dans les éepad c'était
3000 postes en 2023 ce sera 6000 postes
en 2024 de soignants supplémentaires
recruter ce n'est pas qu'une question de
hausse des moyens même si c'est bien de
les garantir c'est aussi une question
d'attractivité et c'est pour ça que ça
ne se fait pas en un jour c'est pour
cela que j'ai obtenu que les infirmiers
et les aides soignants en NP de public
bénéficient de la même mesure de
revalorisation pour le travail de nuit
et les jours fériers que leurs collègues
dans les établissements publics
sanitaires c'est pour cela que j'ai pu
annoncer aussi aujourd'hui son extension
au secteur privé non lucratif parce
qu'il faut encore une fois que sanitaire
et médico-social avance de paire enfin
évidemment je n'ignore pas les
difficultés financières d'un grand
nombre de nos éepades partout sur notre
territoire en plus des mesures de
compensation de l'inflation de 2023 et
2024 nous avons mis vous le savez en
place un fond d'urgence exceptionnel de
100 millions d'euros annoncé avec la
première ministre cet été ce fond il est
d'ailleurs la suite très concrète du
rapport remis au gouvernement par la
députée Christine pierrezbon ces moyens
seront utilisés en 2023 dans le cadre de
commissions départementales qui ont
toutes été installées de depuis la fin
du mois de septembre dédié au suivi par
les agences régionales de santé par les
DDFIP en étroite collaboration et
coordination avec les conseils
départementaux et avec les édus locaux
et les acteurs locaux de chaque secteur
ces commissions à les voocations surtout
à être pérennes au-delà de débloquer ce
fond d'urgence parce que nous devons
pouvoir avoir une cartographie des
établissements et des services d'aide à
domicile département par par département
établissement par établissement service
d'aide à domicile par service d'aide à
domicile à plus long terme vous le savez
le PLF PSS prévoit une mesure
structurante à partir de 2025 la
possibilité de fusion entre les sections
soins et les sections dépendances la
quasittalité des groupes avait déposé
dans le cadre de la proposition bien
viillir cette possibilité nous la
concrétisons dès maintenant dans le
cadre de ce PLFSS pour les départements
qui le souhaitent en lien avec les
besoins de soins qui sont croissants des
résidents nous le savons la sécurité
sociale financera ainsi la section
dépendance des éepad cette
simplification du financement et
l'assurance donc de son équité
territoriale de sa soutenabilité sont
primordiales alors que nous savons tous
ici la situation encore une fois de nos
établissements je souhaite enfin pouvoir
avancer sur la question majeure de la
réforme des fonds de concours des
département je réunis dès ce jeudi le
comité des financeurs c'est-à-dire les
départements vous le savez la CNSA pour
garantir que ça puisse être possible
parce que nous devons cesser cet
empilement des fonds de concours en gros
chaque nouvelle politique publique a
donné donner lieu à un nouveau fond de
concours qui fait que nous avons tous
perdu en efficacité et en lisibilité
nous devons donc engager ce chantier
sans tabout avec un horizon réaliste
pour le PLFSS 2025 au-delà nous le
savons l'enjeu de l'adaptation de notre
société au vieillissement elle ne
concerne pas uniquement les secteurs
médicauxsoaux ou sanitaires c'est bien
toute notre société qui doit sortir
d'une forme de dénis individuel et
collective sur le sujet c'est la raison
pour laquelle je présenterai en
interministériel ce plan d'adaptation et
cette feuille de route le 17 novembre
prochain enfin ce PLFSS c'est aussi un
texte de mise en œuvre de nos
engagements concernant le handicap
notamment ceux annoncé par le président
de la République directement lors de la
dernière conférence nationale du
handicap nous concrétisons une première
année du déploiement des 50000 nouvelles
solutions pour les personnes en
situation de handicap et pour leurs
proches et je parle volontairement de
solution au pluriel parce que nous
devons veiller toujours à répondre aux
besoins et dans toutes leur divers
des familles et des personnes
directement concernées une inclusion qui
ne soit pas donc unisolution pour
garantir par exemple à chaque enfant le
droit à la scolarité y compris en
institut médicaux éducatifs on ne peut
plus avoir des enfants qui ont droit à
une demi- matinée de cours par semaine
assurer une prise en charge adapté aux
enfants en situation de handicap placé
aussi à l'aide sociale à l'enfance et
qui doivent devenir notre priorité
collective notre priorité est donc de
faire en sorte que les 10000 adultes qui
sont aujourd'hui maintenus en
établissement pour offant au titre vous
le savez des amendements cretons puisse
enfin en sortir c'est une question de
dignité que nous devons au personnes
handicapées nous créerons à cette fin
avec les départements les solutions qui
respectent leur volonté qui respectent
celle des familles permettant ainsi de
libérer près de 15 % des places
existantes dans les IME sur le handicap
toujours nous engageons une mesure clé
pour 2025 la création d'un véritable
service public de repérage d'orientation
de prise en charge unifiée de toutes les
situations de handicap pour les enfants
de 0 à 6 ans il s'agit depuis les
services de néonatalité jusqu'au sein
même de l'école en passant par les
pédiatres les services de PMI d'orienter
vers ce service les enfants et les
parents le plus tôt possible pour éviter
toute perte de chance de nos enfants
enfin nous facilitons également la vie
des personnes en situation de handicap
en améliorant leur pouvoir d'achat pour
cela nous supprimons le reste à charge
lors de l'achat d'un fauteuil roulant
concrètement c'est une prise en charge à
100 %. actuellement 90 % des acquéreurs
d'un fauteuil roulant manuel n'ont aucun
reste à charge mais cette situation est
beaucoup moins vraie pour ceux qui ont
besoin d'un fauteuil roulant électrique
près de 60000 Français doivent ainsi
débourser plus de 5000 € pour leur
fauteuil et pour certains modèles très
spécifiques ce reste à charge peut
atteindre plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'euros nous avons donc engagé les
discussions avec tous les constructeurs
alerté aussi par le député Sébastien
petavi pour garantir que ce soit bien
tous les fauteuils tous qui soient
remboursés à 100 % c'est l'engagement
pris par le Président de la République
et qui sera respecté nous y veirons très
très minutieusement avec Fadila katabi
les progrès que j'ai évoqué pour
accompagner les personnes âgées ou en
situation de handicap ne sont possibles
que parce qu'à partir du 1er janvier
2024 vous le savez 0,15 points de la
contribution sociale généralisée soit
2,6 milliards d'euros viendront abonder
les ressources de la 5e branche dont
nous avions voté ici la création j'en
pour preuve que nous consommons la
moitié de ce surplu dès 2024 et que la
trajectoire de dépenses le consomme
quasiment intégralement d'ici 2027 très
concrètement ces ressources
supplémentaires permettront de financer
à cet horizon la totalité des coûts pour
les réformes du tarif plancher de la
dotation qualité des renforts de
personnel en épad et près de la moitié
des 50000 solutions de la Conférence
nationale du handicap pris connaissance
aussi évidemment avec attention de vos
propositions d'amendement majorité comme
opposition
je souhaite que le texte en intègre
plusieurs dont ceux qui s'inscrivent
dans le prolongement de la nouvelle
stratégie pour les aidans que nous avons
présenté avec Fadila katabi le 6 octobre
dernier parce que nous devons mieux
prendre soin de ceux qui prennent soin
des autres être aidant c'est une
responsabilité envers ceux que l'on aime
mais c'est aussi une charge lourde très
lourde physique et mentale pour les
familles nous allons ainsi pouvoir
prolonger si vous voter
l'expérimentation du dispositif relayage
en 2024 quelle je sais les parlementaire
Paul Christophe NOTAM Tib basin très
engagé en attendant une généralisation
que je souhaite mettre en œuvre étant
donné l'utilité du dispositif pour
offrir un répis aux aidents je prends
également à mon compte la possibilité de
cumuler la location journalière du proch
aident pour chaque personne aider comme
le proposeent servanug et Paul
Christophe toujours sur l'autonomie et
même si de nombreuses dispositions
seront adaptées dans le cadre de la
proposition de loi bien vieillir je
souhaite d'ors et déjà saluer la
proposition de développer l'accueil
familial porté par Benoît mournaay cette
solution elle est encore trop peu connue
mais elle permet de proposer un
accompagnement très proche du domicile
et constitue un choix supplémentaire
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap ou les personnes âgées enfin
dans la droite ligne de la politique des
1000 premiers jours de mon souhait de
porter une politique familiale la plus
universelle possible pour toutes les
familles donneront un avis favorable à
l'amendement porté par Nicolas turquis
sur la prise en charge du congé
paternité pour les agriculteurs dont on
sait que malheureusement trop peu
aujourd'hui peuvent l'utiliser
vous le voyez ce texte porte des moyens
en hausse en hausse à la hauteur de ce
que nous devons en tant que société à
toutes les familles qui demeure plus que
jamais comme le disait déjà Simon veille
à cette même tribune il y a 30 ans le
symbole du bonheur quotidien le ciment
de notre cohésion nationale et le garant
de la société de demain je vous
remercie merci Madame le
Ministre la parole est à Madame
Stéphanie Rist rapporteur général de la
commission des affaires
sociales
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre messieurs les ministres madame
la président de la commission des
affaires sociales Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues nous
sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour débuter
l'examen en séance publ du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2024 la semaine dernière en
commission nous avons examiné plus de
1400 amendements c'est un record à
l'issue de plus de 35 heur de débat soit
le double comparé au débat de en
commission à la fin de la dernière
législature ce texte n'a finalement pas
été adopté je regrette que nos
oppositions FFI des nombreux amendement
que nous avons adopté dans l'intérêt des
Français de quoi parlons-nous d'un
budget de la Sécurité sociale de 643
milliards d'euros pour protéger nos
concitoyens soit un/ers de notre
richesse nationale c'est-à-dire quatre
points de plus en moyenne que les pays
européen ce PLFSS que nous avons à
examiner est un texte de responsabilité
collective une responsabilité dans
l'équilibre financier de la sécurité
sociale il acte en effet la poursuite du
redressement des comptes de la Sécurité
sociale le déficit des régimes
obligatoires de base et du fond de
solidarité vieillesse a été diminué de
moitié par rapport à 2022 soit 8,8
milliards en 2023 sur l'ensemble de ce
périmètre les dépenses qui atteindront
610 milliards,9 d'euros en 2023 ont
augmenté de 100 milliards entre 2019 et
2023 ce qui traduit le dynamisme des
dépenses de sécurité sociale en
particulier en matière de retraite et de
santé dans un contexte marqué par le
vieillissement de la population la
gestion de crises sanitaires des
revalorisations salariales historiques
et une augmentation considérable du
niveau des prestation sociale indexé sur
l'inflation concernant l'objectif
national de dépenses d'assurance maladie
il traduit les efforts de notre majorité
pour consolider notre système de santé
en 2023 c'est un N d'â rectifi en hausse
de 3,5 milliards d'euros par rapport à
l'objectif voté il y a un an soit une
progression de 4,8 %. en 2024 l'objectif
national de dépenses pour l'assurance
maladie est fixé à
254,7 milliards d'euros en hausse de 3,2
% un niveau supérieur à l'inflation
estimée à 2,6 %. cela représente une
augmentation de 8 milliards d'euros par
rapport au budget rectifié de 2023 chers
collègues de l'opposition c'est plus de
57 milliards d'euros comparé à 2017 ce
PLFSS est un texte de responsabilité
face aux engagement pris en matière de
prévention et d'accès aux soins ce texte
comporte un volet entier consacré au
virage que nous devons opérer en matière
de prévention cet engagement se décline
au travers du lancement de la campagne
de vaccination contre le papillomavirus
dans les collèges en vue d'éradiquer à
term de nombreux cancers il assure la
gratuité des préservatifs pour les moins
de 26 ans annoncé par le président de la
République en fin d'année dernière ainsi
que le remboursement des protections
menstruelles pour les femmes de moins de
26 ans et les bénéficiaires de la
complémentaire santé solidaire ces
mesures doivent en effet améliorer la
santé sexuelle des plus jeunes la santé
des femmes et celles des plus précaires
les rendez-vous de prévention aux
âgeesclés de la vie assurés par
différents professionnels de santé
seront prochainement ouvert à un grand
nombre de nos concitoyens notre majorité
porte par ailleurs dans ce texte une
mesure importante de
prévention avec la proposition
systématique du dépistage du
comégalovirus chez la femme enceinte
dont les effets sur les futus peuvent
être majeurs en cas de transmission
pendant la grossesse pouvant conduire à
un grand nombre de handicap
neurosensoriels il s'agit de belles
avancées en matière de prévention dont
nous pouvons être fi plusieurs mesures
permettant d'améliorer l'accès aux soins
sont porté dans ce texte tout d'abord
les chirurgiens dentistes pourront comme
ils ont pu le faire durant la crise
sanitaire assurer la régulation de la
permanence des soins dentaires dans les
centres SAMU tandis que les pharmaciens
pourront aussi désormais délivrer les
antibiotiques nécessaire en cas d'angine
ou d'infection urinaire après bien sûr
la réalisation d'un test rapide
d'orientation
diagnostique pour favoriser l'accès aux
médicaments ce PLFSS contient plusieurs
mesures concrètes visant à lutter contre
les pénuries de médicaments et produits
de santé je proposerai par ailleurs que
les prérogatives de l'Agence nationale
de sécurité du médicament et des
produits santé la NSM puisse être
renforcé en matière de police sanitaire
en cas de rupture pour s'assurer d'une
juste répartition des médicaments sur
nos territoires un autre engagement tenu
est celui du président de la République
concernant le financement de nos
hôpitaux et le décloisonnement des soins
entre la ville l'hôpital et le secteur
médico-social la prise en charge de nos
concitoyens pourra être facilité en
effet grâce à l'entrée dans le droit
commun de dispositifs expérimentés en
article 51 posant sur une logique de
parcours de soins renforcés alliant à la
fois les soins de ville l'hôpital et le
secteur médico-social des parcours ayant
démontré leur intérêt notamment dans le
cadre de l'activité physique adaptée
aussi ce PLFSS prévoit la réforme du
financement de l'hôpital qui se traduit
par un rééquilibrage du modèle du
financement des établissements de
santé qui prendra en compte les missions
spécifiques et les objectifs de santé
publique c'est la fin du financement de
tout la toute à l'activité la T2A pour
certains services ce qui va permettre
par exemple de financer plus justement
plus équitablement nos maternités ou nos
service de réanimation également attendu
ce PLFSS prévoit de sécuriser le
financement de l'Établissement français
du sang je suis à titre personnel très
heureuse que les travaux de notre
commission ai permis d'autres réformes
de financement plusieurs amendements
émanant de notre majorité ont été déposé
afin de faire évoluer le financement de
la radiothérapie et de la dialyse une
réforme permettant de garantir des soins
innovants de qualité et d'assurer une
pertinence économique enfin ma
responsabilité en tant que rapporteur
général mais notre responsabilité à tous
est d'assurer l'équilibre de nos comptes
sociaux pour préserver notre modèle de
protection sociale sans faire peser le
poids de la dette sur les futures
générations le solde des régimes
obligatoires de base de la sécurité
sociale se dégradera naturellement en
l'absence de nouvelles mesures je
rappelle que les trajectoires
financières prévoient un déficit de 17,5
milliards eururos à l'horizon 2027 c'est
donc en responsabilité que nous
renforçons dans ce texte les mesures
contre la fraude d'autre part la
construction de londam pour 2024 intègre
des mesures d'économie d'un montant de
3,5 milliards d'euros portant notamment
sur des gain d'efficience et la maîtrise
des prix et des volumes de produits de
santé de telles mesures permettront de
continuer à investir dans notre système
de santé de couvrir les dépenses liées
aux dernières revalorisation qui
représent d'ailleurs plus de 1,6
milliards d'euros dans l'ONDAM rectifié
pour 2023 ainsi je crois qu'aucune autre
majorité ne peut se prévaloir d'avoir
autant investi dans notre modèle de
protection sociale la ligne de crête que
nous suivons vise de manière responsable
à assurer sa pérennité et à préserver la
capacité des génération futur à assumer
leurs propres besoins je vous
remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Caroline
jeanvier rapporteur de la commission des
affaires sociales pour
l'autonomie
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente madames messieurs
les ministres madame la Présidente de
commission madame la rapporteur générale
mes chers collègues dans le cadre de ce
pfss la branche autonomie continue de se
consolider en 2024 avec un objectif de
dépenses fixé à
39,9 milliard d'euros soit une
augmentation de 2,4 milliards d'euros
par rapport à
2023 la CNSA va également bénéficier de
nouvelles recettes en 2024 avec
l'affectation d'une fraction de CSG
supplémentaire soit une hausse de ces
ressources de 2,6 milliards d'euros ces
chiffres sont la traduction de mesures
très concrètes concernant d'abord le
soutien à l'autonomie des personnes
âgées ce PLFSS poursuit la trajectoire
de recrutement de 50000 soignants en
épat d'ici 2030 avec sur cet exercice la
création de 6000 postes
supplémentaires il prévoit également un
soutien à la revalorisation salariale de
ces personnels avec des moyens allouer à
une meilleure rémunération de leur
suggestion de service notamment le
travail de nuit et le
weekend concernant le secteur du
handicap ce PLFSS décline les
engagements dans lors de la Conférence
nationale du handicap CNH en avril
dernier le projet de loi permet ainsi à
l'article 38 la création d'un service
public de repérage et d'intervention
précoce auprès des enfants de 0 à 6 ans
d'un point de vue budgétaire ce PLFSS va
également permettre d'accompagner le
financement de place programmé pour les
enfants et les adultes en situation de
handicap soit là encore la traduction
d'une partie des 50000 solutions à
mettre en
place pour l'accompagnement des
personnes âgées ce PLFSS porte une
mesure très attendue par le secteur des
éepades en créant la possibilité pour
les départements volontaires d'opter
pour un régime adapté de financement
dans lequel les section soins et
dépendant seront désormais fusionné au
sein d'une section unique cette réforme
doit permettre d'alléger les coûts de
gestion des épades et d'en rendre le
financement plus lisible et vise à terme
à réduire les disparités
territoriales c'est une première pierre
à l'édifice que nous devons construire
la réforme du modèle économique des épad
tant la question de la soutenabilité
financière de ces établissement que Cell
du reste à charge des résidents doivent
encore être résolu pour terminer
souhaitit aborder la question du
domicile nous avons voté ces dernières
années des mesures importantes en faveur
du virage domiciliaire ce PLFSS
accompagne financièrement ces mesures et
notamment la réforme de la tarification
et des structures d'aide à domicile je
pense toutefois mes chers collègues
qu'en la matière nous nous heurtons à
l'existence d'une centaine de réalités
différentes du fait du rôle des
départements dans l'organisation et le
financement de ses services nous devons
dès lors collectivement nous atteler à
une réflexion sur
de ce modèle je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Cyril
isibil rapporteur de la commission des
affaires sociales pour l'assurance
[Applaudissements]
vieillesse la
présidente madame la présidente madame
messieurs les ministres madame la
rapporteur générale Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs madame la
Présidente de la Commission des sociale
chers collègues ce projet de loi que
nous examinons aujourd'hui présente la
particularité pour la branche vieillesse
d'intervenir quelques mois seulement
après la réforme des retraites cela
justifie le nombre limité d'articles
relevant de cette branche qui se
cantonne strictement aux mesures visant
à tirer les conséquences de cette
réforme l'article 9 porte une mesure
majeure de simplification du système de
financement du système de retraite
à part à comptter du 1er janvier 2025 la
Caisse nationale d'assurance vieillesse
sera amenée à intégrer financièrement
les régimes spéciaux en cours
d'extinction mesures importantes que
nous avons pris lors de la dernière
réforme ce projet de loi offre ainsi
l'opportunité de clarifier les règles de
financement et d'alléger
considérablement la tuyauterie
financière du
système le redressement de la situation
financière de la branche vieillesse
quier une coopération de tous les
acteurs du système en application de ce
principe visant à flécher vers le
système de retraite l'intégralité des
économies induites par la réforme l'état
versera donc 194 194 millions d'euros à
la branche vieillesse en 2024 au titre
des économies réalisées par le régime de
la fonction publique de l'État cette
participation augmentera au fil des ans
pour tenir compte du rendement croissant
de la réforme concernant l'équilibre
globaux de nos systèmes de retraite nous
avons principalement deux régimes un
régime de base géré par l'État il est en
déficite car il porte l'ensemble du
financement de la solidarité nationale à
côté de ça nous avons un régime
complémentaire l'argir Carco il est
équilibré car il ne participe pas à cet
effort de solidarité une question se
pose celle de savoir si l'argir Carco
doit ou ne doit pas participer à cet
effort de solidarité notamment vis-à-vis
de ses propres propre assuré du secteur
privé ceux qui perçoivent de petites
retraites concernant ce sujet je
rapporte je rappelle que le que le pfss
ne prévoit pas de mesures permettant cet
équilibre l'article 40 permet quant à
lui d'adopter la trajectoire du report
de l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à
Mayotte et à Saint-Pierre et mlon il
permet en NRE de préserver plusieurs
garanties importantes pour nos
concitoyens de ces territoires le
maintien de l'âge d'annulation de la
décotte à 67 ans pour les assurés Maoris
ainsi que l'application du départ
anticipé à 62 ans pour les travailleurs
jugés inaptes au travail la
transposition de l'assurance vieillesse
des aidants de Saint-Pierre mlon afin de
faciliter la validation des droits à la
retraite pour les personnes
s'interrompant de travailler pour
s'occuper d'un proche dépendant enfin
j'aimerais revenir sur un débat
concernant des mesures de prévention
santé débat qui a animé notre commission
l'augmentation du financement de notre
système de soins est lié à
l'augmentation du financement des
maladies chroniques elle représente 80 %
des dépenses du système de santé il est
donc impératif d'accélérer le virage
prmantif qui seul permettent de contenir
l'augmentation de ces maladies
chroniques maladies qui sont évitables
pour ceci il est nécessaire de mettre en
œuvre une politique industrielle de
prévention capable de produire de bons
comportements en santé encourager
l'activité physique une alimentation
saine lutter contre le surpoids
l'obésité promouvoir une santé environ
mental le bien-être physique et mental
nous savons au com bien qu'il est
difficile de changer nos comportement à
quiis depuis le plus le plus jeune âge
en témoigne nos trop nombreuses bonnes
mais souvent vaines résolutions que nous
nous faisons chaque année actuellement
trois facteurs déterminent
majoritairement notre santé le tabac
l'alcool et le sucre en commission nous
avons adopté plusieurs mesures
préventives l'installation d'un prix
minimum par gramme d'alcool qui a permis
en écos de réduire de 13 % de 13 % la
mortalité liée à la à la consommation
d'alcool et seulement en 3 ans la hausse
de la taxe soda élargie au produits
ultra transformés afin d'inciter les
industriels à diminuer les quantités de
sucre qui rajoutent à ces plats et à ces
sodas ainsi dans le cadre d'une
politique de prévention je veux saluer
les mesures portées par le gouvernement
le traitement préventif contre la
broncoolyite la généralisation de la
vaccination contre le papillum virus et
la mise en œuvre des consultations de
prévention aux â clés de la vie je
conserve l'espoir que les votes acquis
en commission sur cette la prévention
seront envoyés en message clair sur
notre ambition de porter une politique
systémique de prévention je vous
remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur paist
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales pour la
[Applaudissements]
famille merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre messieurs les
ministres madame la rapporteur générale
madame messieurs les rapporteurs madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales Mesdames et Messieurs
chers collègues nous commençons
aujourd'hui l'examen du second pfss de
cette législature comme les précédents
ce budget de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 porte des moyens importants en
soutien de notre politique familiale
l'objectif de dépense de la branche
famille est ainsi fixée à 58 milliards
d'euros en hausse de 2,7 milliards
d'euros par rapport à 2023 ces moyens
conséquents doivent nous permettre de
financer les mesures et les travaux
engagés en cours des années précédentes
notamment rappelons-le le chantier des
1000 premiers jours de l'enfant
l'allongement du congé paternité la
réforme du complément de libre choix du
mode de garde ou encore le soutien aux
familles monoparentales ils doivent
aussi nous permettre de financer des
chantiers importants pour les années à
venir et je pense en particulier à la
mise en place du service public de la
petite enfance auquel 6 milliards
d'euros seront consacrés jusqu'en
2027 il y a aussi la réforme du conget
parental qui je sais vous tient
particulièrement à cœur madame la
ministre c'est un travail que nous
devons réaliser collectivement vous vous
y êtes engagé afin de permettre aux
parents qui le souhaitent d'être
présents pour leurs enfants au cours des
premiers mois et années de leur vie tout
en conservant leur niveau au de vie par
ailleurs je tiens à souligner car c'est
important qu'en 2024 comme au cours des
années précédentes nous continuerons à
revaloriser les prestations familiales
afin de préserver le pouvoir d'achat des
familles dans un contexte inflationniste
que l'on sait difficile par ailleurs
notons que ces dispositions sont
renforcées par celles que nous avons
dopté en commission mixte paritaire hier
soir au profit de la mise en œuvre du
service public de la petite enfance dans
le PGL le plein emploi et je sais
combien vous y étiz attaché madame la
ministre et combien vous avez défendu ce
sujet pour terminer je souhaiterai
aborder deux sujets qui me tiennent
particulièrement à cœur sur lesquels
j'ai déposé des amendements d'abord dans
la Contin de la réforme du complément de
libre choix du mode de garde que nous
avons voté l'an dernier il serait
souhaitable de permettre aux familles
monoparental qui bénéficient du CMG
jusqu'au 12 ans de leur enfant de
recourir au service prestataire de garde
d'enfants le mode prestataire est un
maillon essentiel de l'offre permettant
aux parents d'accéder à une solution de
garde adapté aux contraintes
professionnelles en dehors du dispositif
du particulier employeur qui peut
parfois se révéler très complexe et
cronovage pour certaines familles cette
proposition que je porte doit permettre
de rendre la réforme du CMG encore plus
égalitaire pour améliorer l'accès des
enfants à des places d'accueil le
deuxième sujet qui me tient à cœur et
c'est le relayage à domicile vous le
savez madame la ministre le relayage à
domicile des prochédents et plus
généralement le développement du statut
de prochédent le relayage c'est offrir
du répis au proché dents en accueillant
temporairement la personne en perte
d'autonomie au sein d'une structure
d'accueil sécurisée ou en permettant
l'intervention continue d'un
professionnel pendant 36h à 6 jours à
son domicile dans cette perspective les
députés de la majorité ont été nombreux
à proposer la prolongation de
l'expérimentation du relayage à domicile
prévu par la loi ESOC afin de garantir
aux familles qui en bénéficie de la
continuité de la prise en charge de
leurs proches je sais madame la ministre
que vous y êtes également très sensible
et par ailleurs je soutiendrai également
les initiatives visant à créer un droit
renouvelable à la location ère de
prochédent la JPA car de nombreux
Français seront amenés à être plusieurs
fois aidants au cours de leur vie
notamment pour leurs parents et tout
cela finalement en cohérence avec la
nouvelle stratégie de mobilisation et de
soutien pour les aidants 2023- 2027 que
vous portez avec force et détermination
madame la ministre et je tiens à le
signaler je vous remercie de votre
attention je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
François Ruffin rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales pour
les accidents du travail et les maladies
professionnelles merci
beaucoup bonjour madame présidente
excusez-moi je vis pas
saluer un nouveau Pact de la vie au
travail c'est le président de la
République ce printemps en plein conflit
sur les retraites qu'il prometait je le
cite un nouveau pacte de la vie au
travail sera construit dans les semaines
qui viennent et tous les ministres le
juré bientôt grâce à ce nouveau Pact
nous allions je vous cite améliorer les
revenus faire progresser les carrières
mieux partager les richesses aider à la
reconversion améliorer les conditions de
travail bref vous alleiez apporter le
bonheur aux
travailleurs des semaines des mois se
sont écoulés la rentrée passée arrive
l'automn et les budgets où sont ces
promesses ses engagements nous nous ne
voyons rien absolument rien venir car
que se
passe-t-il les Français aiment leur
travail ils en sont fi plus même que nos
voisins européens mais ils n'aiment pas
comment on leur fait faire leur travail
comment on l'organise comment on le
pressurise je suis toujours venu au
boulot avec le sourire me raconter un
chariste mais depuis une paire d'années
la pression qu'on nous met les objectif
qu'on nous fixe je ne tiens plus et les
collègues non plus ce n'est pas qu'un
ressenti dans les comparaisons
internationales nos entreprises sont à
la traaine en bas de tableau les
travailleurs s'y usent physiquement
psychiquement plus vite qu'ailleurs à
cause du temps notamment du temps
resserré contraint étouffant jusqu'au
drame pour les morts du travail nous
sommes en queue de Ploton avec la
Lettonie et la Lituanie we are the
champions alors pourquoi ce mal travail
pourquoi ce mal français c'est un choix
depuis les années 80 dans la
mondialisation les dirigeants
économiques politiques ont fait ce choix
celui d'un low cost à la française
depuis 40 ans le travail n'est pas
traité comme une richesse comme un
investissement non il est maltraité
comme un coût à diminuer à diminué par
les délocalisations à diminué par la
sous-traitance à diminué par la
précarité l'intérim les CDD a diminué
enfin par
l'intensification toujours plus plus
fort plus vite plus de temps
mort mais ce l COST CE bas coup à un
coup oui ce mal travail ce mal au
travail a un coût énorme un coout
gigantesque un coût humain bien sûr pour
les travailleurs c'est leur santé qui
est altérée leur vie parfois brisé ce
sont chaque année plus de 100000
inaptitudes 100000 salariés qui sortent
du travail blessés ou broyés déclarés
inapte 100000 licenciés c'est le plus
gros des plans sociaux et pourtant
silencieux invisible invisible jusque
dans les statistiques car eu ces inaptes
sont les rebus du maltraavail poussière
humaine qu'on jette sous le tapis c'est
un coût pour la sécurité sociale ici
pour son budget avec les accidents du
travail les maladies professionnelles
mais aussi les arrêts de longue durée
c'est un coût pour les sociétés
désorganisé par l'absentéisme par le
turnover c'est un coût enfin surtout
pour la société tout entière dépend de
notre économie de nos services publics
dysfonctionn en peine de recrutement en
pine de compéten de l'aide à domicile au
conducteur de bus des hôpitaux à
l'industrie de l'éducation à la
construction avec des travailleurs que
l'on épuie
qui F ce coup du mal trvail un ancien
ministre Xavier Bertrand l'avait évalué
entre 3 et 4 % du PIB les économistes
les chercheurs le chiffr au-delà bien
au-delà des 100 milliards
d'euros contre ce maltavail contre ce
mal au travail que faites-vous rien vous
ne luttez pas contre tout l'inverse vous
le favorisez oui vous aggraver ce
maltavail vous
l'encouragez mais non qui supprimer les
comités d'hygiène et de sécurité
vous qui a éliminé quatre critères de
pénnibilité le port des charges lourdes
les postures pénibles les vibrations
mécaniques les agents chimiques
dangereux
vous qui promut un sousstatut auto
entrepreneur avec des sous-revenus vous
qui repousse à 64 ans la retraite des
travailleurs à bout vous les assises du
travail ce printemps réclamé je cite un
véritable pacte de confiance reposant
sur coute et la reconnaissance des
travailleurs mais pas l'ombre ici le
rapport tiierry Séna rendu à votre
gouvernement en appelé à une révolution
des pratiques managériales mais pas une
miette
aujourd'hui au contraire au contraire
vos seules mesures ici dans ce budget
c'est de traquer les arrêts maladies
c'est de traiter les malades enfraudeurs
et leur médecins en comp plus une
généraliste réagit ainsi cela revient à
casser le termomètre pour faire baisser
la température si l'on arrête davantage
c'est que les gens vont mal ils sont
cassés j'ai ma patientelle des
caissières ou des femmes de chambre avec
les poignets les genoux et les épaules
abîmé voilà qui devrait être au cœur du
débat voilà l'action que pour les
salariés pour notre pays pour son
économie voilà l'action que vous
ministres vous parlementaires devriez
porter comme vous le promettiez pour
répondre à une aspiration simple partagé
par les millions de travailleurs de
travailleurs qui tiennent notre pays
debout les Français doivent vivre de
leur travail bien en vivre et surtout
surtout bien le vivre que le travail
soit la santé et non pas se la ruiner
je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Michel
Lazan rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des finances de l'économie
générale et du contrôle
[Applaudissements]
budgétaire madame la
Présidente je mets les
lett merci madameés
présidente madame la ministre messieurs
les
ministres madame la rapporteur générale
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales Mesdames et
Messieurs chers
collègues saisi pour avis du projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2024 la commission des
finances en responsabilité l'a adopté
mercredi
dernier le débat d'ailleurs permis de
différencier ceux qui souhaitent
soutenir le renforcement de notre modèle
social et ce qui à l'inverse ont une
conception spécieuse de la solidarité
nationale et de la vie
économique je ne reviens pas sur les
principales données financières qui
viennent d'être citées à cette tribune
toutefois je note avec satisfaction
qu'il repose sur des hypothèses que le
Haut Conseil des finances publiques a
jugé plausible et vraisemblable
d'ailleurs la Banque de France a
initialement plus pessimiste s'est
rallié pour une large part aux
projections du gouvernement
deux autres éléments retiennent
naturellement mon attention en tant que
commissaire aux finances d'cun critique
les allègements sociaux de manière
indiscriminée une réflexion dispositif
par dispositif n'est évidemment pas
interdite mais je veux redire à quel
point nous est donné chaque jour la
démonstration de leur pertinence pour la
santé des entreprises et l'emploi des
particuliers ils sont d'ailleurs
compensé à plus de 96 % par l'État via
des affectations comme celle d'une
fraction de la TVA ou via des
crédits ensuite l'État peut regarder
avec intérêt l'excellente performance de
la caisse d'amortissement de la dette
sociale D cadè car dans un an nous
aurons aurons été apurés pardon
258,6 milliards et resteront à pururé
137,9 milliards d'euros loin d'être une
dépense dont il faudrait se passer c'est
un circuit qui dégage des marges de
manœuvre pour les grands défis qui nous
attendent comme comme celui du
vieillissement au lieu de rester dans
des mains de créanciers pour moitié
extra eururopéen lors de l'examen en
commission des des finances pardon nous
avons également adopté deux amendements
portés par le député belois mournet que
je me et qui me tiennent
particulièrement à cœur à propos de
l'accueil des jeunes en situation de
handicap ces amendements proposent que
la commission des droits et de
l'autonomie soit compétente pour étudier
et proposer une orientation systématique
vers les dispositifs de transition
dès l'âge de 16 ans et que soit
autorisée l'autonomie à la sortie des
IME avec une meilleure coordination des
sphères responsables des enfants et des
adultes pour ce qui est du PLF 2024 il
est regrettable que la Commission des
Affaires social et rejeté ce texte cela
signifie que les oppositions refusent
des dispositifs cruciaux pour la santé
de nos concitoyens je pense par exemple
au lancement de la campagne de
vaccination contre le papillom virus qui
peut peut permettre à terme d'éradiquer
6400 cancers par an mais également au
soutien rehaussé aux établissements de
la branche autonomie et enfin au
déploiement de rendez-vous médicaux
trois âges clés de la vie pour chacun de
nos concitoyens permettant d'informer
notamment les personnes les plus
éloignées du dépistage contre différents
cancers refuser ces mesures est
irresponsable et je et je profite enfin
de cette tribune pour saluer votre
frration monsieur le ministre en faveur
de la reprise des discussions avec la
médecine de ville dans ce pays où les
discussions sont très hospitalocentré il
faut souligner que la médecine est de
ville pardon est un moyen essentiel de
notre système de santé de par sa
proximité avec la
population en conclusion pour poursuivre
la transformation de notre modèle de
protection sociale et pour les mesures
nouvelles qu'il contiennent je vous
invite mes chers collègues à adopter le
PLFSS pour 2024
je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame
Charlotte Parmentier Lecoq présidente de
la commission des affaires
sociales
présidente merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre messieurs
les ministres madame la rapporteur
général madamees et Messieurs les
rapporteurs thématiques et pour avis mes
chers collègues
je commencerai d'abord en mentionnant
l'important travail de consultation et
de concertation qui a précédé pendant
plusieurs semaines notre propre examen
en commission des affaires sociales je
veux notamment parler des comptes de
Ségure auxquel ont été associés
l'ensemble des groupes parlementaires de
la majorité et des oppositions dans une
logique de dialogue avec le
gouvernement je veux aussi parler de la
qualité des nombre audition conduite par
la rapporteur générale Stéphanie Rist et
les rapporteurs thématiques dont je veux
ici souligner
l'engagement ces auditions ont permis
aux membres de la commission des
affaires sociales de recevoir et
d'entendre les préoccupations de
l'ensemble des acteurs de la santé et de
la protection
sociale notre commission a accompli un
examen rigoureux et en profondeur du
texte déposé par le Gouvernement qu'on
en juge effectivement la Commission des
affaires social à siégé pendant 9
séances soit près de 30h c'est bien
davantage que ce qu'avait initialement
prévu le bureau de la commission dans le
cadre de ces travaux les députés ont
déposé
2872 amendements à titre de comparaison
nous en avions 1607 l'an dernier en 10
ans c'est une multiplication par 11
c'est en partie la conséquence de
l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme de la
loi organique qui nous donne 3 semaines
pour expert iser le texte quand nos
prédécesseurs n'avaient péblement que 3
jours il ne fait aucun doute que le
Parlement est mieux informé et que le
travail préparatoire s'inscrit bien
davantage en
profondeur pour autant nous avons pris
le temps d'examiner l'ensemble des
amendements déposés et sommes donc allés
jusqu'à la fin de l'examen du
texte je tiens à souligner la qualité
des débats que nous avons eu dans le
respect des sensibilités politiques de
chacun elle aura permis qu'un certain
nombre d'amendements issus des rangs de
la majorité présidentielle et de
plusieurs groupes d'opposition
parlementaires soient adopté 94
précisément parmi eux 39 étaient issu
été issu d'un des trois groupes de la
majorité et portant de véritables
avancées sociales avec des mesures pour
l'hôpital comme la mise en place d'un
financement forfaitaire pour la
radiothérapie et la dialyse mais aussi
des mesures de prévention je pense au au
remboursement des préservatifs féminins
pour les moins de 26 ans à
l'expérimentation du dépistage prénatal
du
citomégalovirus ou encore à la demande
de rapport sur l'opportunité d'élargir
la campagne de vaccination contre le
papillomavirus au-delà des
collèges poursuivant cette logique de
construction et d'ouverture 55
amendements qui émané des opposition ont
été adopté qu'il s'agisse de récupérer
l'ensemble des cotisations sociales de
l'Assurance Maladie pris en charge au
bénéfice d'un professionnel de santé
fraudeur de réintégrer tous les
médicaments dérivés du sang dans
l'assiette de la contribution sur le
chiffre d'affaires des entreprises
pharmaceutiques ou de renforcer le
repérage des troubles pour les mineurs
accompagnés par les services de
laaz et puis parce que c'est à cela que
sert aussi notre travail en commission
les débats nous auront permis de rejeter
un certain nombre d'amendements
caricaturaux et irresponsables d'un
point V
budgétaire je n'énumérerai pas ici le
nombre d'amendements augmentant les
taxes et cotisation à
tout dans un contexte marqué par une
forte inflation et une hausse des prix
de l'énergie notre responsabilité et de
rassurer et de donner de la lisibilité à
nos entreprises plutôt que de les
soumettre à des impôts
supplémentaires je considère pour ma
part que l'objectif du plein emploi
reste la manière d'augmenter les
recettes de la sécurité sociale c'est le
sens de la politique que nous menons
depuis 6 ans et je salue le compromis
trouvé hier avec les sénateurs sur le
projet de loi pour le plein
emploi le travail de la commission aura
également permis d'écarter un nombre
considérable d'amendements
particulièrement discriminants visant
des personnes étrangère en situation
régulière sur notre territoire rappelons
que tout cela est contraire à notre
Constitution au traités européens et à
nos
valeurs malheureusement après toutes ces
heures de débat dans de bonnes
conditions et malgré l'adoption du texte
à 90 % l'alliance de circonstances des
opposition de la France insoumise au RN
aura conduit au rejet du PLFSS en
commission c'est une première c'est
aussi une forme de gâie et je regrette
que les amendements adoptés ne puissent
être présentés défendus par nos
rapporteurs au nom de la
commission la Commission n'a donc pas
adopter le PLFSS nous n'avons donc pas
de budget ni pour les établissements de
santé ni pour nos soignants ni pour la
protection
sociale la
majorité prendra ses responsabilité
elle votera pour la hausse de long d'AM
au-dessus du niveau de l'inflation et la
la poursuite de l'augmentation des
rémunérations et des embauches à
l'hôpital et dans les éepades
elle votera pour la création de
nouvelles solutions pour les personnes
en situation de handicap et le
renforcement du diagnostic préco chez
l'enfant
elle votera également pour
l'augmentation exceptionnelle des
dépenses de la branche autonomie pour
améliorer l'attractivité des métiers
adapter l'offre médico-sociale aux
besoins démographiques et renforcer la
qualité des accompagnements
elle votera enfin pour des avance des
investissements majeurs en faveur de la
prévention et de l'accès aux soins en
particulier des plus jeunes et des plus
vulnérables et pour le renforcement de
la lutte contre la fraude aux
cotisations c'est ce que les Françaises
et les Français attendent de nous je
vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à monsieur Éric
ocrel président de la commission des
finances de l'économie générale et du
contrôle
budgétaire
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres notamment monsieur le ministre
Rousseau j'ai le plaisir quand même à
revoir sur ce bon euh mesdames les
rapporteurs
euh malheureusement il est
vraisemblable
que le travail qui a été fait en
commission sur le PLFSS comme il avait
été fait en projet de loi de finances en
pcture soit balayer
d'un revers de 493 tout simplement parce
que ce projet de loi est minoritaire
alors je vais y venir sur le vote qui a
eu lieu en commission des affaires
sociales mais je voudrais rappeler que
il n'est pas seulement minoritaire dans
cette assemblée le 5 octobre il a été
rejeté par le Conseil de la Caisse
nationale de l'assurance maladie et par
le Conseil de l'Union nationale des
caisses d'assurance maladie les
organisation syndicale de salariés inter
professionnels représentative la
Fédération Nationale de la Mutualité
française l'Union nationale des
associations familiales la Fédération
nationale des accidentés et du travail
des handicapés France assut santé se
sont aussi prononcé contre et enfin le
16 octobre il a été dénoncé par les cinq
fédérations hospitalières du pays dans
une lettre ouverte adressée à la
première ministre donc oui vous êtes
minoritaire ici et on le voit dans les
organisations représentatives et c'est
vrai que les articles actant le
sous-financement de système de
protection sociale ont été supprimés et
du coup le texte aussi rejeté lors du
vote en commission tout simplement parce
que ce texte en réalité revient à une
situation entre guillemets normale
c'est-à-dire normal d'avant covid
c'est-à-dire au moment d'un
sous-financement chronique de l'hôpital
public je me rappelle d'une anecdote
c'était en 2018 le président de la
République est face à des soignants dans
un hôpital des soignantes et ces
soignantes lui disent la souffrance de
l'hôpital public les manques de
personnel les manques de revenus et je
me rappelle que le Président de la
République leur avait dit il n'y a pas
d'argent magique 2 ans après il a bien
fallu trouver un peu d'argent magique
quand même pour faire face au covid
notamment parce que justement l'hôpital
publici avait été mis dans une telle
situation qui lui était effectivement
très difficile de surmonter la crise
sanitaire que nous avons connu et voilà
que nous revenons justement dans cette
situation à la fin du quoi qu'il en
coûte où à nouveau on sousfinance la
santé publique et l'hôpital public le
déficit structurel des hôpitaux devrait
s'aggraver en 2023 en raison d'une
explosion des coups de éergie en
conséquence les fermetures de lui
continuent les structures d' d'urgence
sont obligées de fermer temporairement
cet été les fermetures ont concerné près
d'une structure sur deux ce sont aussi
les soignants qui subissent cette
situation leurs conditions de travail se
sont fortement dégradées et leur
revalorisation sont insuffisantes pour
permettre le choc d'attractivité promis
malgré la diminution du pouvoir d'achat
qui menace la consommation populaire le
reste à charge continue d'augmenter au
détriment de la santé des plus pauvres
selon un sondage IFU de septembre
dernier c'est ainsi que 37 % de la
population qui a déjà renoncé à des
soins des équipements médicaux alors
qu'il en avait besoin mais aucune de ces
mesures de ce PLFSS ne répond à ces
besoins les objectifs de dépenses sont
insuffisants long dame pour 2024 devrait
augmenter de 3,2 % soit une évolution
légèrement supérieure à l'inflation 2024
mais insuffisante pour rattraper la non
compensation de l'inflation de ces deux
dernières années pour la Fédération
hospitalère de France ce sousfinance des
hôpitaux s'élève à plus de 2 milliards
d'euros c'est un véritable effort
financier qui est ici imposé aux
établissements de santé en conséquence
on s'achemine vers un système de santé à
deux vitesses où le public est de plus
en plus distancé par le privé c'est
aussi aux travailleurs que ce Tex
attaque en instillant le soupçon de
recours illégitime à leur droit ce PLSS
prévoit effectivement de renforcer les
modalités de contrôle sur les médecins
prescripteurs et les assurés bénéficiant
d'arrêt maladie ou encore de limiter à 3
jours la durée des arrêts prescrit lors
d'une téléconsultation si le
gouvernement veut enrayer la hausse du
volume des indemnités journalières qu'il
cherche d'abord à lutter contre
l'explosion des risques psychos-ociaux
le recours aux arrêts maladies n'est
effectivement pas un luxe pour les
salariés je tiens à rappeler au ministre
que selon une étude d'un groupe de
protection sociale bien connu 25 % des
arrêts ne sont pas pris ou de façon
partielle et que 37 % de la population
déclare avoir travaillé plusieurs fois
par semaine alors qu'ils étaient malades
ce n'est donc pas sur ces économies que
le gouvernement devrait compter voilà un
peu la situation de ce plsfs et de
l'autre côté ce sont encore 87 milliards
d'exonération et de réduction sociale en
2023 qui ont été accordés
majoritairement aux entreprises les plus
grandes et les plus polluantes revenez
plutôt du coup à des recettes dont une
fois de plus vous privez ou que vous
compensez par la TVA dont ce n'est pas
le rôle face à cette situation
préoccupante différentes prises de
position vous ont obligé à reculer fort
heureusement sur certaines mesures
injustes notamment venu des bancs euh de
laanupes comme la hausse des franchises
médicales la ponction de la gicarco ou
la réforme des modalités d'indemnisation
du déficit fonctionnel permanent
j'espère que le recours au 493 sera pas
l'occasion de les réintroduire ce choix
ne ferait qu'accentuer votre entreprise
de destruction à petit feu d'autres
modèle social pourtant déjà bien attaqué
par les mesures présentées merci merci
je vous
remercie j'ai reçu j'ai reçu de Madame
Mathilde Panon et des membres du groupe
la France insoumise une motion de rejet
préalable déposé en application de
l'article 91 aléa 5 du règlement pour la
présentation de cette motion la parole
est à Madame Caroline
[Applaudissements]
Fiat
présidente merci madame la présidente
Madame et messieurs les ministres madame
la Présidente de la Commission madame la
rapporteur générale Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale a été
rejeté en commission c'est donc en toute
cohérence que j'arrive devant vous pour
défendre cette motion de rejet au nom de
mon groupe la France insoumise j'apprend
par contre en toute incohérence que
certains ne la voteraient pas alors
qu'ils ont voté contre ce projet en
commission parce que c'est moi qui la
défendrai on m'avait dit de travailler à
l'école quand j'étais petite j'aurais
fini M est peut-être à droite ou pas
ainsi certains voteraient cette Mo ne
voteraient pas cette motion hélas je ne
suis qu'une aide soignante insoumise
donc il ne la voterait pas ça s'appelle
avoir des convictions à géométrie
variable pour citer un illustre
député sachez que je ne plierai pas je
ne m'enirai pas en silence je ne me
soumettrai pas je ne me retournerai pas
je ne me conformerai pas je ne me
coucherai pas je ne me Terai pas et non
chers collègues je ne renoncerai jamais
à vous convaincre même si vous êtes
sorti de cet
hémicycle que ce soit dit si ce texte a
été rejeté en commission c'est parce
qu'il ne donne aucun moyen pour sauver
notre système de santé au bord du
gouffre prenons l'exemple de l'article 2
l'ondame 2023 n'est pas du tout
suffisant on l'a dit l'année dernière
mais personne ne nous a écouté et
résultat il faut rajouter de l'argent
mais la rallonge est toujours très
insuffisante tout le monde vous le dit
il dimme pour l'ondame 2024 c'est
pourquoi il faut voter cette motion ce
n'est qu'une suite logique d'autant plus
pour toutes les personnes ici présentes
qui ont applaudi les soignants durant le
confinement car ce texte ne le rend
absolument pas hommage donc non il ne
s'agit pas d'un comportement
irresponsable non nous ne sommes pas des
inconscient il s'agit un de respecter la
volonté qui s'est exprimée en commission
avant l'arrivée du 40 93 et 2 de mettre
fin à la CE de notre système de santé il
y a de très bonnes raisons de rejeter ce
texte d'autant plus dans le contexte
très inquiétant dans lequel nous
l'examinons l'hôpital est en crise
inédite dont la situation des urgences
montre l'intensité combien de patients
ont trouvé porte close devant l'hôpital
les appels aucun sont totalement
engorgés alors que faire quand les
urgences sont fermées qu'il n'y a
personne au bout du fil cette situation
vous paraît caricaturale c'est pourtant
ce que vivent bon nombre de nos
concitoyens tous les services sont en
pénurie de soignant récemment ce sont
même les services de néonatologie qui
ont fait l'actualité pas de lit pas de
personnel pour prendre en charge les
nouveau nés ce qui met gravement leur
vie en danger les chiffres la mortalité
infantile publié récemment nous ont
d'ailleurs tous choqués car en France en
2023 ils augmentent je vous parle
aujourd'hui au nom de toutes ces
familles qui vivent un cauchemar
poursuivons en parlant des épades les
multiples alertes n'ont rien donné la
maltraitance institutionnelle est
toujours le le quotidien des résidents
et des soignants le privé lucratif lui
continue de distribuer des dividendes
pendant que les résidents n'ont même pas
le droit à une toilette réglementaire et
sont rationnés décidément leur gris fait
recette y compris avec l'argent public
l'état de la santé mental de nos
concitoyens est alarmant nous croisons
tous dans nos permanences des personnes
déprimées anxieuses et désespérées de ce
que vous leur faites subir plus d'un
quart des Français consomment des
anxiollytiques des antidépresseurs des
somnifères et autres médicaments
psychotr et que dire de la santé mentale
de nos enfants si dégradés en
établissement psychiatrique c'est aussi
la fermeture de lit le manque de
personnel et parfois la contention faute
d'autres moyens vous avez des troubles
vous faites une crise il n'y a personne
pour s'occuper de vous ce sera donc la
contrainte physique ou médicamenteuse
bienvenue en France en
2023 regardons aussi ce qu'il en est de
la santé au travail les accidents du
travail son légion et l'exposition au
risque psychosociaux est de plus en plus
élevé nous avons vu encore cette é des
personnes obligées de travailler sous
des chaleurs caniculaires les
conséquences sur la santé sont
dramatiques peu importe pour vous chacun
doit être au travail à tout prix et
maintenant en nous forçant à travailler
2 ans de plus après votre réforme des
retraites que ce PLFSS continue à mettre
en œuvre pendant ce temps la France est
aussi devenu un désert médical géant
dans lequel les patients ne trouvent
même plus de médicaments pénurie
d'amoxicyine pénurie de traitement pour
les maladies chroniques pénurie de
vaccin contre la bronchyolite pardon et
j'en passe nous sommes sollicités
quotidiennement par des personnes
paniquées de ne pas trouver leur
traitement on atteint des sommets quand
votre solution à la pénurie est de
demander qu'il ne soit plus prescrit le
ridicule serait presque risible si ce
n'était pas aussi grave et quand je
prends l'exemple de la cortisone dont
tant de gens ont besoin aucune réponse
également le non recours au soins enint
des chiffres jamais vu faute de moyens
ou de service de proximité les gens
renoncent à consulter à se faire des
PIST et bien sûr dans un cercle vicieux
infernal tout cela grave d'autant plus
leur état de santé dans votre monde de
la naissance à la mort personne n'est
épargné il n'y a qu'un seul mot pour
qualifier votre bilan la catastrophe et
ce PLFSS ne fera qu'aggraver la
situation c'est pourquoi je défends avec
vigueur cette meçon de rejet pour 2024
c'est l'austérité maximum notre système
de santé ne survivra pas votre politique
cette année nous l'avons tous vécu dans
nos territoires fermeture des urgences
fermeture de services de maternité et
j'en passe nos concitoyens manifestent
encore et encore pour sauver ce qu'il
reste de leur service de santé mais vous
n'entendez rien c'est aussi cette colère
qui s'est exprimée lors du rejet de
votre texte en commission pour la
branche autonomie un financement très
loin des besoins établis par tous les
rapports rien que pour aboutir à un
ratio personnel résident correct il
faudrait 10 milliards d'euros de plus
selon le rapport Fiat ibora vous
prévoyez à peine 4 milliards d'ici 2020
27 il serait temps de nous donner le
rapport que nous avons vé l'année
dernière dans cet hémicycle ou bien
est-il si si embarrassant pour vous tout
ce que vous savez faire ce sont de beaux
cadeaux à l'industrie pharmaceutique par
contre pour les plus fragiles les plus
précaires c'est la double peine il
paraît que vous auriez abandonné le
projet d'augmenter les franchises
médicales tant mieux nous espérons
vivement que cette augmentation du reste
à charge ne reviendra pas par la fenêtre
notamment par voie
réglementaire dans la partie dépenses
c'est aussi la Valance de mauvaises
idées diminuer les arrêts de travail
soi-disant non justifié en contrôlant
toujours plus les malades et les
médecins qui font leur travail rien pour
le handicap des miettes pour les
victimes d'accidents médicaux rien pour
la psychiatrie triste état des lieux
mais non vous avez l'air content et
motivé pour vite très vite accélérer et
continuer de foncer dans le mur on
s'interroge alors sur votre sur votre
incompétenence peut-être que vous
pourriez du coup écouter la multitude de
propositions que nous vous faisons j'y
reviens
pour améliorer la situation mais non car
la réalité est ailleurs la situation de
notre système de santé relève de choix
politiques délibéré oui notre système de
soins subit depuis 30 ans les
conséquences de politiqu austéritair les
logiques capitalistes ne laissent aucune
place au bien-être des individus pour
vous c'est la politique du chiffre qui
compte sans vous soucier des êtres
humains qu'il y a derrière depuis des
décennies vous faites de la santé un
marché sans vous préoccuper de
l'essentiel et vous aggraver siamment le
sous-financement chronique du système de
santé l'épidémie de covid aurait pu vous
servir de leçon vous venez d'ailleurs
d'être condamné pour mauvaise gestion de
stock des masques et mauvaise
communication sur leur utilisation mais
non vous ne vous remettez jamais en
question la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale est une invention
bureaucratique qui loin d'être une
boussole pour améliorer la santé de nos
concitoyens est au contraire une
contrainte budgétaire derrière laquelle
vous tentez de vous cacher l'industrie
pharmaceutique s'acapare la santé avec
votre bénédiction elle décide du tout
des prix des médicaments de leur
quantité de production de leur
acheminement jusqu'au plus haut franc
vous faites le droit de dans son intérêt
puis vous l'encourager avec les fonds
publics Sanofi bénéficie chaque année de
millions de crédits d'impôt recherche
pour finalement licencier ses salariés
et lorsque leur sof d'argent g gageche
des milliers de vies vous regardez
ailleurs je parle bien sûr du scandale
de la dépquine vous fermez des lits
d'hôpitaux mais vous engressez les Big
Pharma vous dites qu'il n'y a plus
d'argent pour pour les éepades mais vous
en avez temps à offrir au cabinet de
conseil qui vous aide à privatiser
toujours plus notre système de santé pas
d'aesage pas de grand planans pour les
aidants rien pour les personnes en
situation d'handicap mais des milliards
d'exonérations de cotisation pour les
entreprises tout cela résulte de votre
volonté vous décidez où vous mettez
l'argent ou et où vous ne le mettez pas
ce qui mérite votre considération et ce
qui n'en vaut pas la peine vous qui avez
qui n'avez que le mot responsabilité à
la bouche il est temps d'assumer la
vôtre d'assumer que la marchandisation
de la santé c'est votre programme
politique il en résulte inévitablement
d'une dégradation de ce servicees public
essentiel vous comptez les lits vous
comptez les salaires vous comptez les
médicament vous comptez les soignants
vous comptez les actes médicaux et alors
fatalement nous comptons les malades
nous comptons les morts nous comptons
les personnes maltraités vous ne voyez
pas des patients mais des consommateurs
vous ne voyez pas des usagers d'un
service public mais des clients et vous
répétez un lassablement des éléments de
langage en espérant nous tromper par
exemple vous dites les urgences sont
tenues mais que si signifie tenir quand
elles ont été obligées de fermer que
signifie tenir quand tous les soignants
sont épuisés que signifie tenir quand
tant de patients perdent une chance
d'être soigné voir de vivre et nous ne
sommes pas les seuls à le dire les cinq
fédérations hospitalières sont vent
debout contre un projet de loi qui Act
un plan d'économie jamais vu le texte ne
convint pas non plus les instances des
différents régimes d'assurance maladie
nous avons également reçu des alertes de
toutes parts des associations des
professionnels qui n'en peuvent plus des
directions d'hôpitaux qui croulent sous
les les déficites une fois de plus vous
faites l'unanimité mais contre vous et
pour cacher vos fautes vous vous en
prenez au plus faible comme s'ils
étaient responsables de leur pathologie
ou de leur mal leur mal-être au travail
la sécurité sociale est un bien commun
que vous ne pouvez souffrir alors de
PLFSS en PLFSS vous la détricoé vous
êtes les architectes de la destruction
de notre système de soins cela ne peut
plus durer c'est pourquoi il faut
rejeter ce texte nous nous proposons une
toute autre politique nous proposons le
100 % sécu le zéro reste à charge la fin
des épates privés lucratifs
l'augmentation des salaires pour toutes
et tous la fin du numérus apertus la fin
de la maltraitance institutionnelle la
réouverture de lit une politique
nationale en santé mentale la fin des
exonérations de cotisation le ratio de
soignant par résident un pôle public du
médicament et tant d'autres vous dites
que les milliards ne tombent pas du ciel
mais nous vous avons trouvé l'argent par
exemple taxer les milliardaires et et là
je vois déjà encore vos têtes àeurer
mais il faut leur faire confiance si on
leur propose par exemple mon plan grand
âge et autonomie pour stopper la
maltraitance institutionnelle avec les
résidences seior tes que nous les
imaginons je suis sûr qu'ils vont se
préciper précipiter non pas pour fuir
dans un autre pays mais pour sortir leur
chéquier pour adhérer au projet ils ont
montré avec les restos du cœur par
exemple qu'ils sont capables d'être
généreux alors pourquoi ne pas leur
demander pourquoi vous en prendre
toujours aux plus pauvres parce que
peut-être parce queux ne peuvent pas
fuir vous demandez toujours plus
toujours au même y compris pour
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans vous demandez
toujours plus à des millions de Français
pendant que quelques-uns sont toujours
tranquilles nous proposons une logique
totalement inverse de la vôtre partir
des besoins de santé voilà aussi
pourquoi nous défendons cette motion de
Roger à tous les collègues pour vous
pour vos explications de vote j'anticipe
ce que vous allez dire pour ceux qui
veulent débattre et qui vont me dire
qu'ils ne peuvent pas la voter cette
motion de rejet parce qu'ils veulent
débattre le seul débat qui aura lieu
dans cet hémicycle ce sera de savoir
quel jour et quelle heure madame la
Première ministre ellisabeth vorne va
annoncer le 493 et nous avons vu la
situation en commission alors chers
collègues il nous il nous reste un seul
vote pas sur ma défense pas sur mon
étiquette mais sur le fond la motion
nous avons supprimé l'ondame indigne et
pourtant ce vote ne sera jamais respecté
alors cons les hypocrisies avec ce
gouvernement il n'y a aucun débat
pourtant personne ici ne refuserit de
voter des crédits pour le service public
de la santé ce que nous refusons c'est
de voter l'austérité au détriment de la
santé la première ministre va arriver
pour dégainer son 493 et mettre un peu
plus dans le gouffre notre système de
santé toutes celles et tous ceux qui ne
voteront pas cette motion il
participeront alors chers collègues en
cohérence si vous avez voté contre ce
PLFSS en commission voter en cohérence
et voter pour cette motion de
Reet je vous
remercie et nous en
venons chers collègues nous en venons
aux explication de vote sur la motion de
rejet la parole est à Monsieur non la
parole est d'abord à Madame Laurence
Christol pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente à
titre personnel
même si l'esprit d'agitation de certains
n'y aide pas je prends toujours les
critiques des oppositions au sérieux
vous voulez généralement du débat on en
a eu on a traité de tous les sujets de
l'ondâ de la prévention de l'accès aux
soins du médicament de l'autonomie de
l'Éternel concour l'épine de la
meilleure taxe près de 3000 amendements
déposés en commission et d'un coup non
plus de débat vous refusez le débat par
principe je rejette donc je suis alors
avec la France insoumise on n'est pas
une incohérence près mais avec votre
motion de rejet c'est quoi c'est le
rejet des 640 milliards de budget de la
Sécurité sociale c'est le rejet de la
généralisation de la vaccination
HPV c'est le rejet des rendez-vous de
prévention c'est le rejet de la gratuité
des préservatifs et des protections
périodiques c'est le rejet des 2,8
milliards pour l'attractivité des
métiers et le soutien des soignants
c'est le rejet de la réforme du
financement des éepad et des
établissements de santé c'est le rejet
des nouveaux droits pour les aidanss
alors peu importe vos gesticulations
nous sommes fiers de porter un budget de
solidarité et de responsabilité pour les
Français nous voterons donc évidemment
contre cette motion je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Benz pour le groupe
rassemblement
national merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
madame la rapporteur générale présidente
de commission chers collègues nous
sommes dans une situation ubuesque et
assez paradoxale on nous demande de
voter pour ou contre une motion de rejet
sur un texte budgétaire lui-même rejeté
en commission des affaires sociales en
attendant le 493 pour un nouveau passage
en force du gouvernement qui n'a su ni
écouter ni composer avec les oppositions
avec vos 493 vous forcez sans cessent
les Français contre leur volonté celle
sortie des urnes en juin 2022 nous nous
vous forçons à les écouter cette
situation paradoxale elle est de votre
responsabilité à vous gouvernement
d'Emmanuel Macron elle est la
conséquence de votre méthode brutale
avec le Parlement et donc avec les
Français ou plutôt contre les Français
votre 493 la semaine dernière sur le
projet de loi de finances nous a appris
que votre méthode a changé en pire
désormais le passage en force se fait
avec absence totale de débat puisque
nous n'avons pas pu examiner un seul
amendement du PLF en hémicycle
nous souhaitons le débat c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous nous étions abstenus
sur la motion de rejet aujourd'hui nous
avons rendez-vous avec le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale le
spectre d'un 493 dans les heures à venir
ne peut nourrir sainement et utilement
le débat parlementaire indispensable
c'est dommage car ce texte pourrait
contenir des avancées concrètes pour les
Français le groupe du Rassemblement
national a d'ailleurs déposé des
centaines d'amendements en ce sens il
est encore temps de vous raviser et de
laisser les débats se poursuivre et
peut-être même de voter chers collègues
les amendements de bon sens que nous
proposons pour améliorer ce texte dans
ce PLFSS 2024 il y a à la fois des
risques de dégradation de notre système
de santé ou encore des restrictions sur
le transport médical mais aussi des
propositions que nous saluons d'autant
que Marine Le Pen les avait elle-même
proposé lors de l'élection
présidentielle notamment concernant la
tarification à l'activité ou encore la
délivrance à l'unité de médicaments
opposition constructive le rassemblement
national veille à la bonne construction
des textes que le gouvernement nous
présente la parole est à Monsieur
Frédéric Mathieu pour le groupe la
France
insoumise merci madame la présidente
madame la Présidente collègues mesdames
et messieurs les ministres le rapport de
la macronie au budget de la Sécurité
sociale c'est le rapport un gigantesque
holdup l'année dernière déjà 84
milliards d'exonération de cotisation
sociale net sont passé via le 493 cette
année on nous propose 80 milliards
d'exonération de cotisation sociale net
qui vont sans doute passer par le 493
autrement dit en deux budgets sur une
année 164 milliards d'exonération de
cotisation sociale quand on pense au
13,5 milliards de peut-être déficit en
2030 que vous avez prétexté pour voler 2
ans de vie aux Français c'est une honte
et oui une honte alors quel estessence
politique de tout ça mesdames et
messieurs certains indulgant avec vous
diraient que vous êtes des mauvais
gestionnaire je pense qu'au contraire
vous êtes des excellents gestionnaires
vous avez compris qu'il faut ruiner les
recettes de la SQ pour mieux la tuer car
vous haïissez la SQ vous haïissez la SQ
à travers ses exonérations de cotisation
sociale vous haïissez la SQ en faisant
de chaque assurée sociale un fraudeur en
puissance qu'il faut soupçonner en
permanence vous vous aïissez la SC en
parlant de Ch privé dans comme un
feignant qu'il faut remettre au travail
même le vocabulaire vous pose problème
monsieur le ministre
casenav articulé après moi cotisation
sociale pas charge cotisation sociale
mettez-vous ça dans le crâne avec
quelques cours d'orthophonie vous y
arriverez alors vous voulez effacer une
partie de l'histoire de ce pays une
partie de l'histoire sociale une partie
d'un projet de civilisation qui
finalement à travers sociale n'est rien
d'autre que la réalisation du fraternité
de la devise républicaine vous avez le
projet antirépublicain de ruiner la SCU
de la sabrer de la remettre au privé
voilà votre projet voilà pourquoi nous
proposons cette motion de rejet pourquoi
nous la soutenons merci votre
attention je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Yannick noer pour le groupe
les
républicains madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
madame la rapporteur général madame la
Présidente effectivement nous sommes à
un moment historique puisque ce PLFSS a
été pour la première fois et bien
déboutter en commission des affaires
sociales c'est pas un un vote non
construit non réfléchi c'est un un vote
parce que le compte n'y est pas le
compte n'y est pas sur un certain nombre
de choses que nous avons déjà exprimé en
commission des affaires sociales
notamment sur la branche famille avec on
l'espère et j'espère que la ministre l'a
entendu universalité sur les allocations
familiales sur effectivement la branche
autonomie puisque nous souhaitons avoir
un financement pérenne qui va pouvoir
permettre de diminuer le reste à charge
des familles et enfin sur la branche
santé le compte n'y est pas pourquoi
parce que tout le monde est mécontent
vous l'avez vu nous avons eu les
fédérations
hospitalières privé publi les féap
uNICANCER les 1,5 milliards à 2
milliards pour faire face à l'inflation
et aux augmentations de charges ne sont
pas pourvu le secteur libéral n'est pas
mieux LTI avec l'absence de
revalorisation tous ces acteurs du
domicile qui malheureusement ne voient
leurs actes non non revalorisé avec un
coût de transport notamment pour le
domicile non pris en charge nous avons
également les mêmes les mêmes
problématiques sur un certain nombre de
de de de secteurs donc le compte n'y est
absolument pas est-ce que pour autant
c'est l'occasion de voter pour une
motion de rejet la réponse est non
également mes chers confrères puisque
nous souhaitons effectivement le groupe
les républicains aller jusqu'au bout de
la démarche pouvoir soutenir un certain
nombre d'AM amendement et je dirais à
Madame Fiat qu'il ne s'agit pas de la
lutte des classes avec le médecin de
droite et l'aide soignante de l'extrême
gauche parce que je vous rappelle chers
je vous rappelle chers collègues que
quand vous avez porté la proposition loi
sur la réintégration des soitenants nous
vous avons soutenu parce que c'était une
bonne proposition donc nous nous
souhaitons au niveau des républicains
être utile pour notre pays être utile
pour la santé des Français et améliorer
ce texte du Gouvernement je vous
remercie et je vous informe que sur le
vote de cette motion nous aurons un
scrutin public à la demande du groupe la
France insoumise le scrutin est annoncé
la parole est à Madame ma peetit pour le
groupe démocrate merci madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues sous
cette mandature malheureusement la
caricature remplace bien trop le travail
de fond tel une crise de rébellion ou
d'adolescence c'est selon perpétuel
selon certains de nos collègues ils
s'oppose par principe sans jamais
vouloir faire avancer notre pays en
faisant fi de nos contraintes
institutionnelles on remarquera
d'ailleurs qu'en commission lorsque les
caméras des médias sont plus éloigné les
propos sont plus constructifs la posture
moins théâtrale mais dans l'hémicycle on
juge bon de paralyser le débat quand on
ne va pas jusqu'à vouloir le supprimer
les textes inhérents au budget méritent
pourtant davantage de sérieux davantage
d'ambition nos concitoyens méritent
notre p mérite bien mieux que cette
mascarade de principe car quand on
s'intéresse réellement à ce que propose
ce projet de loi de finance de la
sécurité sociale on note des mesures
ambitieuses en matière de prévention la
vaccination les protections hygiéniques
pour lutter contre la précarité
menstruelle les préservatifs masculins
et féminins gratuit pour les assurés de
moins de 26 ans dans la continuité du
Ségure de la santé un effort
significatif de 3,3 milliard ard d'euros
pour mieux rémunérer les personnels
médicaux et paramédicaux les prémisses
d'une mise en place d'une solidarité à
la source la lutte contre le déficit de
la Sécurité sociale la lutte contre la
fraude sociale la lutte contre la
pénurie de médicaments introuvable pour
certains en
France proposer une motion de rejet mes
chers collègues est une action purement
démagogique alors plutôt que de le faire
disparaître le groupe modem souhaite
débattre de ce texte et pour toutes ces
raisons le groupe motem votera contre
cette motion de rejet je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Jérôme
GCH pour le groupe socialiste et
apparenté merci madame la Présidente
s'il devait y avoir qu'une seule raison
de voter cette motion de rejet c'est
pour nosou parlementaire la certitude de
pouvoir se prononcer sur ce PLFSS car
nous n'aurons probablement assurément
certainement aucune autre possibilité de
se prononcer sur ce PLFSS comme l'année
dernière nous ne l'avons pas eu vous
avez commis une erreur l'année dernière
en la répétant cette année c'est
diabolique vous le savez et donc c'est
la première raison pour laquelle il nous
faut nous prononcer sur cette motion de
de rejet favorablement la deuxième
raison nous y reviendrons
euh un jour c'est sur les insuffisances
chroniques et constantes notamment sur
la fixation de long d'â prévu dans ce
PLFSS qui ne permettra pas de répondre à
la crise de l'hôpital public et à la
crise des éepades puis la troè raison et
là je veux le dire avec beaucoup de
solennité aux deux ministres qui ne nous
ont pas dit la même chose tout à l'heure
c'est qu'au moment où nous parlons nous
ne savons pas le contenu de ce PLFSS sur
deux dispositions essentielles est-ce
que vous allez faire oui ou non la
ponction des réserve de l'agir Carco et
bien les deux ministres ne nous ont pas
dit la même chose est-ce que vous allez
oui ou non doubler les franchises
médicales et bien là aussi les ministres
ne nous ont pas dit la même chose et
c'est proprement hallucinant que au
début de l'examen d'un texte de des
dispositions fortes et spoliatrices
prévues par ce texte et bien il n'y ait
pas de clarté de la part des ministres
qui pour l'un nous dit en commission ben
le débat nous permettra de savoir si
nous allons doubler ou pas les
franchises médicales l'ondame tel qu'il
est prévu à à entériner cette
trajectoire d'économie sans que nous
ayons pu avoir le moindre débat
là-dessus et puis la dernière raison la
dernière raison mes chers collègues
c'est de la cohérence démocratique quand
un P FSS pour la première fois de
l'histoire des PLFSS est rejeté en
commission avec ce message fort qui
atteste à la fois des objections que je
viens de mentionner et de la
démobilisation de la majorité alors
soyons cohérents rejetons-le aussi dans
l'hémicycle je vous remercie et je vous
demandais je vous demanderais mes chers
collègues de faire un peu moins de bruit
s'il vous plaît la parole est à Monsieur
Frédéric Valtou pour le groupe horizon
et app oui madame la Présidente merci
beaucoup quelle situation paradoxale
Mesdames et Messieurs les les député
insoumis une fois de plus vous appelez
au débat mais vous voulez empêcher ce
débat avec cette motion de de rejet
préalable une fois de plus comme à
chaque fois vous souhaitez intervenir
avant même la discussion générale avant
même que vos orateurs puissent exprimer
le fond de la vie pour empêcher ce débat
alors nous sommes plus surpris puis que
finalement à chaque texte qui est
proposé à chaque réforme vous proposer
une motion de de rejet quel que soit le
texte quel que soient les les
investissements et en la matière ça a
été rappelé par le ministre et ça sera
rappelé lors de la discussion générale
il y a en matière de santé des
investissements dont il serait utile de
discuter queles que soient les réformes
vous êtes toujours pour le le rejet vous
avez vous-même pourtant déposé plus de
530 amendements en commission que nous
avons discuté dont certains nous ont
permis d'avoir d'avoir des discussions
tout à fait tout à fait utiles voilà la
réalité vous abandonnez le le travail
que nous avons fait en commission des
affaires sociales 35 he de débat près de
plus de 1000
amendements débattus pour écarter d'un
revers de main cette ce PLFSS par cette
motion c'est un budget de 103 milliards
d'euros pour les hôpitaux c'est la
revalorisation de 5,2 % des des pensions
des retraites c'est la revalorisation à
hauteur de 3,3 milliards d'euros des
salaires des personnel soignant que vous
voulez écarter comme ça d'un revers de
main vous savez madame Fiat je m'adresse
à vous parce que nous conna son tous et
nous apprécions nous apprécions tous je
pense la qualité de la force de votre
engagement nous savons la force de vos
convictions mais je pense que vous VZ
mieux que ça de défendre une motion de
rejet sur un texte comme le PLFSS pour
empêcher justement le débat que nous
allons pouvoir avoir alors évidemment
vous avez compris madame la Présidente
que le groupe horizon serait contre
cette motion de de rejet j'ai bien
compris merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame marielotte
Garin pour le groupe
écologiste merci dans le
silence je veux d'abord saluer ce qu'il
y a de positif dans ce budget de la
Sécurité sociale pour 2024 que vous nous
présentez la gratuité des préservatifs
et des protections menstruelles pour les
moins de 26 ans le lancement d'une
campagne nationale de vaccination contre
les papillomavirus dès la 5e l'évolution
du financement des épades et les tout
petits prémisses de la transition
écologique des établissements de santé
pour autant ces quelques mesures diluées
ne suffisent pas à cacher le
verrouillage des dépenses de santé par
votre logique d'austérité budgétaire
permettez-nous donc d'émettre de sérieux
doutes quant à la sincérité des budgets
qui nous sont présentés aujourd'hui très
concrètement pour chaque budget de la
Sécurité sociale que vous nous présentez
on se retrouve à systématiquement devoir
rectifier l'objectif de dépense de
l'assurance maladie et si je prends
l'exemple des hôpitaux comment
voulez-vous qu'ils puissent prévoir
durablement leur trajectoire financière
avec un tel raffistolage budgétaire les
rafistolages budgétairees ça n'est
jamais de bon signe mais pour 2024 nous
sommes partis particulièrement inquiet
et nous ne sommes pas les seuls la
Fédération hospitalière de France pointe
un abondement nécessaire de 2 milliards
supplémentaires pour couvrir les besoins
de cette année on vous parle de couvrir
le coût de l'inflation et les dépenses
d'investissement et vous nous répondez
la maîtrise des dépenses ce cadre là où
chaque mesure de progrès s'accompagne
d'une mesure d'économie nous le rejetons
vous osez aussi lancer la chasse aux
arrêts maladies désormais seule porte de
sortie pour les Français en souffrance
au travail après vos réformes de
l'assurance chômage et des retraites et
en doublant la franchise des médicaments
vous faites peser sur les Français la
pénurie des médicaments tout en arrosant
d'argent public les industriell
pharmaceutique qui délocalise à
l'étranger l'effondrement climatique a
commencé l'année 2023 sera l'année la
plus chaude jamais connue les restos du
cœur ne sont plus en capacité de fournir
l'aide alimentaire au plus fragiles les
maladies chroniques explosent et
frappent d'abord les plus précaires et
quelle est votre réponse aux 12 millions
de personnes atteintes d'affection
longue durée il faut maîtriser la
dépense et à cela nous ne pouvons y
souscrire nous voterons donc pour cette
motion de rejet je vous
remercie et pour le dernier orateur
inscrit je vous demanderai un petit
effort sur le bruit mes chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Yannick Mony
pour le groupe de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine merci madame la Présidente
moi je fais juste TR trois
remarques d'abord quand même quand vous
êtes à cours d'argument vous dites un
peu n'importe quoi depuis tout à l'heure
puisque dans votre méthode il suffir
d'être d'accord pour adhérer à ce que
vous proposez j'ai même écouté certains
députés de la majorité expliquer qu'il
fallait absolument débattre alors que
personne n'ignore que ce texte passera 2
493 mais il faudrait quand même vous
rappeler une chose pourquoi ce texte a
été rejeté en commission c'est pas un
caprice des oppositions c'est que
simplement la majorité n'était pas
mobilisée en commission et le texte il a
été rejeté à deux voix près donc
vousmême vous n'y croyez pas à ce texte
et les députés que nous
sommes
ma deuxième remarque j'ai écouté je sais
plus si c'est je crois que c'était le
ministre tout à l'heure qui nous a fait
un plaidoyer sur la nécessaire austérité
en matière de dépenses de santé et ben
c'est justement ça que nous contestons
dans votre texte c'est que vous vous ne
partez pas des besoins d'ailleurs votre
texte c'est l'expression de votre
ignorance des besoins en matière de
santé nous on considère que le plan FSS
c'est un problème de recette c'est pas
un problème de dépense on part des
besoins et on va chercher les recettes
qui correspondent au besoins dont on a
dont les citoyens
dernière chose dans votre discours pour
Sir votre texte vous avez sensiblement
sorti les mêmes arguments l'année
dernière mes chers collègues depuis un
an qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans le
pays en matière de santé est-ce que
l'hôpital va mieux est-ce que la
médecine de ville va mieux est-ce que
les gens accèdent mieux à la santé et
ben non c'est pour ça qu'on votera pour
cette suppression je vous
remercie et je vais donc mettre au voix
par scrutin publicette motion de
préalable le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos résultat du scrutin votant 404
exprimé 395 majorité 198 pour 180 contre
215 l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas
adopté